Adam, should we do the show?
I don't see why not.
I don't know man, I don't know.
I understand.
But you know what?
What?
F it.
I think we, listen, it's either do it
or let's just get the hell outta here
and have a good day.
We're gonna do it, let's do the show.
Fine.
♪ Born In 1966 ♪
♪ A man of many talents ♪
♪ And the will to push through ♪
♪ Rich Roll ♪
♪ He turned his life around ♪
♪ He wasn't doing so hot ♪
♪ Rich Roll ♪
♪ He got rid of that weight and he gained a lot of wisdom ♪
♪ He lives in a tent ♪
♪ Rich Roll ♪
Thank you all so much for playing along.
And I hope you have a wonderful night
and I'd like to welcome to the stage Mr. Rich Roll.
(continuous guitar music)
Hey, everybody.
Welcome to another edition of "Roll on."
Where journalist, author, mask-wearing friend of whales
and generally pleasant human, Adam Skolnick
and I dive into matters that range
from deeply grave on the one hand
to fairly dunderheaded on the other.
Today, I would say leans heavily into the latter
with a light dusting of somewhat controversial topics
before a little bit of wonderful, we're calling the Rollies.
Stay tuned for the Rollies.
Slice of wonderful.
The first annual Rollies.
And then closing with a coaching call check-in
with friend of the podcast, Chris Howarth,
holding my hand to the salty water fire in this lead up
that I find myself in
towards an impending 12 and a half mile open water swim
that I made the unfortunate mistake
of putting on my calendar.
But first, how goes it my periodically guild friend
of feathered pen and fin fishes?
You know, I need a feathered pen.
I'm surprised you don't have one.
I know I need one,
but the problem is I've been into a business mode lately.
I've been putting the finishing touches on my business plan.
I can't wait for this.
For the spa space.
Okay. Do tell.
So if you're like me, you love a forgiving mirror
and a scale that's a little bit light.
Am I right?
Doesn't everyone love a that?
A little funny mirror
that makes you look skinny and handsome?
Not a funny mirror,
you want it to be like.
Just tweaked a little bit,
Tweaked enough to where like it's slanted down
or something, so yeah.
They can compress like the way that you appear in them.
So you look maybe 15, 20% spelter.
Okay, well get me that guy's email
because I need that.
So I want that,
and then we're gonna monkey with the scale,
so are like two and a half pounds light.
So you come to my spa, you have the treatment,
you work out, you do whatever you wanna do.
And then you see yourself in these mirrors
and you get on the scale and you leave so happy.
And as soon as you step out,
we hit you with a full scale membership pitch,
six months in advance and you will pay it.
This is the idea?
This is my idea.
Yeah, and I assume that you anticipate scaling
this scale idea to become the new unicorn
in the wellness space?
Yeah, this is it, baby.
That mean 10 years from now,
I will be the bad guy in the Netflix show
with a billion dollars in my pocket.
Do you have charisma to be able
to be the front man for this?
Well, maybe not.
To walk into the soft banks,
and score those $200 million series B financing rounds?
I might need like a fake German,
or like an Israeli partner
that can really get in there.
All right, well, this plays into what we're gonna
talk about later in the show about self mythologizing.
No, but in, in all series...
So, I like it.
Yeah, thank you.
I might come to you for,
during my series A.
Is it serie or series?
Series get your VC talk straightened out first.
Because serie is double A.
Serie is double A by the way.
Not double A.
But I'm honestly, I'm nervous to be in Calabasas today,
because this is kind of Calabasas adjacent.
It's ground zero right now for...
I know, Will Smith could be anywhere.
Yeah, we got the Will Smith situation,
which we're gonna get into
a little bit later in the show,
also adjacent to Taylor Hawkins
who lives nearby as well.
So lots to talk about.
Can I say one more thing
before I finish my end of the hellos.
You know, you ever get off the mic and you wish...
First of all, hold on.
What the name of the spa endeavor?
The name of my spa.
Yeah, what are you gonna call it?
You look great baby.
I think you need like a techy word.
Like the one word that doesn't really mean anything.
Okay, Spatastic.
Yeah, but that's not what I'm talking about.
But with like an exclamation point.
Put a pin in that and we'll figure that out.
All right, lets spitball it.
All right, what else were you gonna say?
Well, you ever get off the air
and you just wish there was one thing
you wish you'd said?
During the four by four recap,
I never thanked everyone for the lovely messages
and all the encouragement.
I got a lot of encouragement from listeners
and people who are paying attention.
And I really appreciate it, really does help,
it makes a big difference in the motivation.
I don't know, I'm sure Jason feels the same way
and I just wanted to thank everybody.
Very cool, well said.
Right on. Well, let's get into it.
First thing I wanna say is we just introduced the show
with a little bit of a tweak on the theme song
that you guys heard.
You might be wondering where that came from.
That is the very talented noble son,
who's a Vancouver musician, as well as a voiceover actor.
Apparently he's huge on TikTok.
He's got a massive TikTok following
where he does voiceover type stuff
and people share it like crazy.
Anyway, he was the live musical act
when I did this live event in Vancouver a couple months ago,
maybe several months ago at this point,
where he introduced me for this event
that we did in a church, this live podcast.
And he was kind enough to let us share it
and he's poking fun at me,
and I thought it was all in good spirited fun.
Some people can handle being poked fun at,
some people can't.
Well, another thing we're gonna put a pin in
and talk about in a little bit.
Meanwhile, I feel good, my swimming is ramping up.
Yeah, what does that mean ramping up?
You're going to, like I noticed on Instagram.
More consistent, little bit increase in the volume
as I head towards this 12 and a half mile swim
that I'm gonna do in June.
Four and 5K swimming? swim sessions right?
Yeah. I mean, Chris, you know, I check in with Chris,
which is gonna be the latter part of this show,
and he'll talk us through, you know,
the whys and the how behind all of that.
But actually the more I swim, the better I sleep,
which means I feel better during the day.
So it all feeds on itself.
And I'm going to Miami later this week for a speaking thing,
I'm gonna get there a little bit early and stay a day later
so I can get in some good ocean swims in the warm water.
So I'm looking forward to that.
Nice. You wear the jellies.
I know that's a thing there for sure.
Hopefully it won't be too much of a problem. Anyway.
I don't know in winter or when this time of year,
if it's that bad,
I think it might be more of a later spring summer thing.
Yeah, I'm not sure either.
I will find out and report back.
All right.
Meanwhile, the first thing that I wanna talk about
is the sudden death of Taylor Hawkins, dead at 50.
I have to say I didn't see this one coming,
the beloved drummer for the Foo fighters.
And apparently I just found out this morning,
you told me this,
I knew that he had been complaining of chest pains,
but apparently there were 10 drugs in his system.
Well, I think I told you
that I knew he had had a drug problem
because it was in the obit I read.
Because I didn't, you know, I'm not the guy,
I've never been like...
A drug problem that was in the past?
Well he'd had it,
and then I saw someone else on Twitter
who was in that you'd retweeted, I think.
Or you had even said, you know, check on people.
Like, you know, a lot of people who've had,
who've either relapsed or overdosed.
Remember that you shared?
Jessica Lahey
Right. Jessica Lahey's tweet.
And I think she must have been referencing Taylor Hawkins.
So that's when I kind of read his obit
and found that out.
It's like, there must be something to these rockers
that they kind of like, they get to a certain age
and they're questioning,
or even at any age questioning like,
"Why me? Why do I deserve it?" Or somehow.
Well, I think you're reading into something
that we don't really know anything about.
Who knows what's...
No, I mean, he's quoted as saying something like that.
Oh he is?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wow.
Yeah.
Yeah, this is a tough one because he was young.
I mean, he was 50, but he looked quite
a bit younger than that.
Very vital, a guy who seemed
like he was super friendly with everybody.
Nobody has a bad thing to say about him.
And you know, like you had mentioned about Calabasas,
like he lived in hidden Hills.
His family still lives there obviously.
He had lived Topanga before that
and I would see him out when I would go trail running.
I'd see him out mountain biking all the time.
He's always out there.
So this is a sad one, man, you know?
And it goes to that point of,
you know addiction doesn't discriminate,
doesn't matter who you are,
how rich you are, how successful you are
and you know...
So even if you sober for a period of time?
Right, exactly.
That must be like that.
What do you think about that as a sober person
when you hear something like a relapse like this,
that ends this way,
do you always feel like it's right there,
it could happen at any time?
Well the adage is that your inner addict
is doing pushups in the dark all the time,
just waiting for that moment of weakness to express itself.
And I experienced that when I relapsed,
it was like it picked up and went from zero
to a hundred in the blink of an eye.
So it is beneath the surface at all times,
and I know what that feels like.
I'm reluctant to say anything specific to Taylor Hawkins,
because I don't know anything about, had he been sober?
Did he relapse?
Has he been using the whole time? Who knows?
I don't know, but relapse is a part of recovery
and people think of relapse as this huge failure,
but in reality, the miracle is, you know,
each day that goes by that the addict
or the alcoholic doesn't use or drink,
and sort of keeping that in perspective
because as the yearning is so strong
and it's cunning, baffling and powerful.
So it's not surprising when somebody
who has a long term sobriety relapses.
So it's not like shocking in that regard,
but it's just sad in this case because he was, you know,
somebody who did seemingly have it all
and was loved by a lot of people,
and seemed at least when you would see him in photographs
or in videos to be enjoying his life, right?
Which makes it confusing.
Maybe the confusing part is that life is always,
it's definitely harder for some people than others
and there's harder situations than others.
I'm not saying otherwise,
but like there's always a blade.
There's always a knife's edge nearby
in everyone's life, it's not easy to deal with life.
Nobody gets out of life alive.
You know, and nobody gets out of life without pain
and suffering and obstacles.
So we project onto these very successful people
who are very good looking
and have everything that we aspire to have ourselves.
Oh, that's so sweet to say that about me.
And imagine that they live these lives
that are without any kind of toil or consternation or pain,
and it's just not the case.
Like every single person that I've ever met,
no matter their life circumstances
is going through something and it's inescapable.
So obviously he had some kind of issue
that he was contending with and it's just sad
and it's heartbreaking to see this happen.
He lived a great life.
His mom gave him drums when he was a teenager.
I think it was, or maybe even a little like 10 or 11.
He was one of those kids that was into rock,
like before most people his age
or into music before most people his age.
And he was going to shows,
and his mom gave him that drum him set
and it just opened up his world from what I read.
And he just always wanted to be a rockstar.
And that way he is like, John Frusciante, is it John?
Yeah.
John Frusciante
Yeah, Frusciante
Long time herein after he was really young.
He was kind of a wonder kin guitarist
that hooked up with Flee and then Flee brought him in.
And he's the guy that was basically
the guitarist on the Rick Rubin records,
"Californication" and "Blood Sugar Sex Magik,"
that kind of made the punk pop in a way.
But then they had to part ways with him,
then he came back to the band for a period of time.
Yeah, so, but he's not in the band now.
But same idea, like, you know,
kind of always knew he wanted to be a rocker.
It's true, a lot of these guys,
I mean, Tyler and Trapper,
Trapper got his first drum set
when he was, I don't know, eight, seven,
something like that.
Tyler picked up a guitar when he was about the same age
and never looked back.
So I've seen that play out.
I saw also that Travis Barker
had shared something on social media
about his history with Taylor.
Like they were, you know, young,
did Taylor grow up in Orange county?
I don't know.
He said Taylor would go to his shows
and they knew each other at a very young age.
So they've been in it for a long time.
Wow.
Anyway sad.
Rest in peace.
Yeah. What else do we want to talk about?
Oh, I wanted to quickly mention that Julie,
Julie had a booth at the Oscar's gifting suite,
which was really cool.
So she came back with all these stories
of meeting all these cool people.
The way these things work though,
like they set up these hotel ballrooms or whatever,
and there's a bunch of vendors in there
and they usher these celebrities in
and the idea is they get to partake in the products
and all that kind of stuff.
And are picture taken with the people,
the owners of these companies.
And it's kind of like a PR sort of thing.
I think there was maybe only one Oscar nominee
or two Oscar nominees of the whole thing though.
It's it's generally all these other celebrities,
like there's this whole weird eco system...
Is it the days before or is it?
Yeah, it was like Friday, Saturday before the Oscars,
but Karsh came by.
Look at that.
And some other cool people.
Greg Grunberg, Viola Davis,
somebody from "Euphoria" that Julie met.
Anyway, she had fun over there.
Yurkash was in my living room this weekend.
He was.
Well, he was on the television.
All right because you were watching the dropout?
Yeah.
We're gonna talk about that too.
He's great. He's always great.
Yurkash is blowing up.
He's inescapable now he's in so much stuff.
He's fabulous. He's always great.
He's always entertaining.
He's always good.
Yeah.
You want to talk to us about Oz?
Yes. Oz Pearlman, Oz the Mentalist,
attempts to break Robbie Ballingers central park record.
It's happening on April 8th.
I don't know how the exact dates,
but the earlier this year or last year, was it last year?
Yeah, middle last year, before...
Can remember when Robbie did, it was within the last year.
When did you do your 10,000 event?
It was right around then.
That was like last spring, I can't remember.
Anyway, Robbie's first time around Central Park,
running in Central Park ever,
was apparently doing loops around Central Park.
And he was trying to have the most miles logged
or the most loops around Central Park
during its opening hours.
I guess it's open from 6:00 AM to 1:00 AM.
There's five hours closed.
And he wanted to have the most loops.
He ended up running a hundred miles,
and that is the new record for Central Park.
And Oz is going to try to break that record.
Oz says that, you know,
for him running Central Park is hallowed ground.
He says, he knows every pebble on that course,
he's been running there so much for his entire life.
So he's gonna be doing it to raise money
for "Save the Children Ukraine."
He is trying to raise $100,000.
He's personally putting in 10, he told me,
and he wants everyone to kick in.
If you're interested, he says,
he's gonna be doing loops all day from 6:00 AM,
starting at the engineer's gate.
And you can join him for the loops.
He's gonna be running at a pretty quick pace.
He's a great runner, but you can join him,
you can just kind of cheer him on,
he'll finish around midnight or 1:00 AM.
He's gonna try to do 100 miles plus one or two loops.
So we'll see how he does.
And he's in touch with Robbie.
Apparently Robbie's been really gracious
and encouraging and wants him to break it.
That's Good to hear.
They're in communication over this thing,
because I'm very protective of Robbie.
Oh yeah?
Yeah, Robbie's my boy.
But Oz we should say came here and did a podcast.
It's an unbelievable podcast.
It has not published yet.
So the audience is like, "who's Oz the mentalist?"
Oh, you'll find out.
We talked about him the other day,
but he's a very interesting human
who has a very particular skill that is bewildering,
and also happens to be
this incredibly accomplished ultra marathon runner.
So this is an interesting challenge that he set for himself.
And given my friendship and allegiance with Robbie,
it'll be interesting to see two podcast guests vie
for the title of this Central Park loop record.
When you have former podcast guests
who become friends really,
I mean, you stay in contact?
FOPs.
When you have certain FOPs going head-to-head
for something like this, has this happened before?
Or is this the first time?
I don't know if it's happened in this way before.
Really?
But it's fun to see FOPs in the wild,
like FOPs at the Oscars.
That's always cool.
Did you get any FOPs?
There was a couple,
well Travis Barker was playing drums on stage.
And then Tony Hawk gave out an award
with Kelly Slater and Sean White.
Okay, that's cool.
Those two guys have been trying to get on the podcast
and have come close a couple times,
but still hasn't worked out.
Who else?
Maggie Bard, mom of Billie Eilish.
Was caught on camera being thanked by Billie and Finneas
after they won their Oscar the other night.
I don't know.
Well, it's cool.
It helps you feel more connected
to what these people are doing out in the world.
It is cool,
I think your listeners probably feel the same way.
And this is the first time then FOPs
are gunning for...
Well, they're not doing it at the same time,
it's not quite a Colin versus Lou situation.
No, no.
But it is Oz trying to take Robbie's Central Park title.
Again, that's engineers gate, April 8th, 6:00 AM.
Where's engineers gate?
It's at 90th and fifth avenue,
and he's running counterclockwise.
He says his crew will be set up at the gate
with posters and signs.
They're expecting hundreds of runners throughout the day.
So that's what he's saying.
And it's being publicized to the local running clubs.
That's how it's gonna happen.
Yeah. Cool. Right on.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome,
but I wanna snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know actually already
know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans,
and legumes into their daily routine.
Sadly however, without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly,
and because I want everybody to experience some version
of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say is the plant power meal planner,
our affordable all in one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious, and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches,
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off in annual membership
when you use the promo code "RRHEALTH" at checkout.
This is life changing stuff people,
for just $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com
promo code "RRHEALTH" for $10 off and annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
Right on, all right. Well, let's keep things moving.
We have so many things to talk about.
I think we're about to really step in it now,
because we're gonna talk about NCAA swimming
and in particular, the controversy surrounding Lia Thomas
and what has been transpiring
in the world of competitive swimming,
women's competitive swimming
and the sort of role of transgender athletes in sport.
And this is a very heated topic obviously.
Opinions are pretty inflamed around this,
which has made it difficult to talk about it
and in any kind of objective sense.
Actually, we even talked about it weeks ago,
about is it something that you want to get into, right?
Yeah, I have misgivings
about even talking about it at all,
because I think people have their minds made up
about this and it's certain to alienate certain people
or you know, set certain people off.
But I also think it's a really important thing to talk about
and it falls squarely into terrain
that I care about as a competitive swimmer
with a long history and love for this sport.
And also as somebody who cares deeply about human rights,
civil rights and the transgender movement.
I have transgender people in my life that I care about,
transgender people in my family.
So I'm very close to this issue,
and I feel like it would be cowardly
to not talk about it on some level,
as sort of nerve wracking as it can be
to kind of unpack something
that is so hotly debated at the moment.
And I feel like this case is in some regard,
like the ultimate test case,
because perhaps it's not the first instance,
but one of the first instances
in which a pretty elite level swimmer decides
to transition from male to female,
putting them in a position to succeed on a level
that perhaps they wouldn't have been able to otherwise.
I mean, you came up with a couple other test cases
that I'm less familiar with.
Yeah, there was an athlete named Juniper Eastwood
who won running events
from the University of Montana and Cece Telfer
at a place called Franklin Pierce University.
She won the 2019 Division II national championship
in the 400 meter hurdles.
So, which is Division II,
this is Division I and swimming, it's a different level.
It doesn't sound like Cece Telfer was vying
for the overall national championship.
So it's a little bit different in that case,
and it's just a more high profile case.
And it's coming at a time
when this issue is in the forefront.
Really the issue is this tension between inclusion
and fairplay and whether or not these two things
can coexist in any kind of meaningful way, right?
Or perhaps they're irreconcilable in a case like this.
So with respect to Lia,
this is somebody who was born genetically male,
started swimming at five on the men's teams.
And I think part of the narrative that's out there
that's misguided is that as a male swimmer,
wasn't that successful or wasn't that great,
but I actually pretty good.
One of the Ivy league's best swimmers,
he finished second in the men's 500, 1000
and 1,650 freestyle, the Ivy league championships
as a sophomore.
So when you look at them on paper, as a male,
weren't gonna make the Olympic team,
but still rather fast in the grand scheme
of being a male competitive swimmer.
Of course began to transition,
and then during the pandemic,
when nobody was competing,
used that year to continue this transitionary process
and emerged at the NCAA championships this past year
with I think 34 months of a hormone therapy under her belt.
And prior to that, going to the Ivy league championships
and like slaughtering everyone
and winning all of these races,
which I think put her on the map.
And finally one of the fastest times,
I think in the country at the 200 in that championship.
Correct, and so that really kind of put the whole issue
on the national news map,
and then made her sort of a hot potato
for the right wing to kind of weaponize
this controversy for political points.
We've seen a lot of that lately and...
You mean blow hard politicians trying to use something
to make themselves more powerful?
A little bit of that, right?
Some fear mongering around that.
And this is a really tricky one because on the one hand,
it's pretty clear from a purely objective point of view
that this hormone therapy
that Lia has undergone does not eradicate advantages,
that she was able to accrue by living as a man
for the better part of her life, right?
Or going through puberty as a male.
Yeah, going through puberty,
developing, you know, the muscles
and all of that, that goes into that.
And then 34 months of hormone therapy
is not really gonna undo all of that.
But what is that, just pills?
I don't really even know actually.
I think it's hormone therapy,
but I don't know if it's...
I think it's predominantly pills.
I should know more about that than I do.
She goes into that NCAA championships.
And what's interesting is there was an expectation
that she was just gonna wipe the record boards clean
and just crush everybody,
but she actually only won one event.
She won the 500 free.
Because she won that first one.
And it seemed like it was setting up for that, yeah.
But she didn't win any other events.
And her time in the 500 free
was quite shy of Katie Ledecky's time.
She went 4:33, Katie Ledecky's record is 4:24.
It's a pretty significant difference.
She got fifth in the 200 free,
and was that the only other individual event that she..
Wasn't she in the hundred as well or no?
I think she swam on the hundred.
But she was never a contender in the hundred,
I don't think, but she did swim in the hundred I think.
Did she?
I thought so, or maybe I'm wrong.
So just to break this down,
when she was a male, she was 554th in the 200 free.
And then she went to top ranked as a female.
And her 500 free transitioning from male to female,
her time difference was six point or 6% slower as a result
of that transition.
And when you look at the differences...
In the 500 you're saying?
In the 500, yes.
And when you look at the differences between male
and female performances in that event,
the range is typically about 10 to 11%.
So her time difference being just 6% different
means that you could infer from that,
that she gained somewhere between four and 5% in advantage.
And you're saying then in 200,
she went from 554th ranked as a male
to the top ranked female,
but that's before the championships?
Yeah, because she got fifth.
In the 500 free, her ranking went from 65th to first.
And then in the 200 free back to the 200,
her time difference was just 3.76 slower
in an event that typically has a seven to 8% advantage
when you compare males to females.
So there does seem to be a gap here.
And I think it's important to point out
that, first of all, not for a moment,
do I suspect that Lia's intentions in transitioning
or anything but pure,
like there's a great sports illustrator article in fact,
I think it's the only article
where she actually goes on the record
to talk about this at all.
And when you read that, you realize like,
this is a person who really feels like
they were in the wrong body.
And this transition is an attempt
to be authentically who she is.
Yeah, this is not a craving, lust for a medal.
This is not,
"I'm gonna transition so that I can be better at my sport."
I mean, that's ludicrous.
That is ludicrous in this case.
That is probably the fear driving a lot of these people nuts
that are against.
Right extrapolating on that,
there's gonna be a wave of people
that are gonna transition
so they could dominate their sport.
There's no evidence to suggest
that anybody would actually do that,
but that is part of the fear.
That is the fear.
Issue of course.
So her motivations being pure in that regard,
I think it's important to recognize.
And I think it's also important to recognize
that she didn't break any rules.
Like she adhered to all of the NCAA
and USA swimming rules regarding her ability to compete.
So to vilify her I think is misplaced emotion.
We can have a conversation about the fairness of the rules
that the NCAA has set up regarding this.
But I don't think that should be aimed in Lia's direction.
I read somewhere early on in all this before the NCAA
that, and this came to third party.
So I don't even know if she feels this way
that she saw herself as a Jackie Robinson,
and that rubbed me wrong.
Yeah, that's a tough one.
That's not fair.
Yeah, I mean, it's a little bit ludicrous to compare that,
but I don't know that that came from her.
I don't know either, I hadn't heard that.
In terms of the fairness versus inclusion landscape though,
obviously we want to create a situation in sport
where everybody can be included.
And we also wanna create a terrain
in which it's fair for everybody.
And I think there is a cogent argument
to be made that this is not fair,
the way the rules are currently written
and the science is still emerging.
But to say that this type of hormone therapy
for this amount of time will create a situation
where the playing field is fair,
I think we're seeing that that's not the case.
And I'm very sympathetic to the female,
the young women athletes who have to compete against Lia.
And it's not a binary thing.
Like this is a difficult thing
because I also believe that Lia should have
the opportunity to compete,
but how do we create a situation
in which fairness becomes a rubric
by which we're establishing that fair playing field?
And I don't have the answer to that.
It's a tough one.
I'm with you.
The way I kind of think about it is,
there's elite athletics and there's athletics.
And when it comes to athletics,
just youth athletics inclusion is priority.
You gotta let people be,
you gotta let people have access to it.
I don't think your high school sports teams are elite.
Sorry to say.
So when it comes to a high school level,
if there's someone who identifies in a certain way
and they want to compete, I say you open the door to them,
because you're not,
just because you're on a varsity team,
doesn't make you elite.
When it comes to national championships and gold medals,
I think that's where it becomes a little bit dicier.
I think one year on testosterone is not enough, obviously,
but you had just painted a picture.
It was actually 34 months,
so it's closer to three years,
which for my understanding is the Olympic standard
that now the NCAA has just adopted,
they've just changed from one year to three years.
I think it's 36 months now.
Did they adopt that?
NCAA just changed it to the Olympic standard.
Right, which it's a three-year period.
So unless you begin your transition in high school,
you're probably not gonna be able
to compete in collegiate athletics.
But you were saying that Lia actually
had 34 months of testosterone.
Yeah, she had 34 months.
So she was close to it.
But she's a fifth year fresh or fifth year.
Yeah because she read shot of the year.
But she was close to it,
and she still was based on these numbers,
had an advantage though.
So that 36 months is questionable.
Right, that's what I'm saying.
Like I don't think that hormone therapy
for X number of months fully considers all the variables
that come into play in terms of performance.
I agree. And I don't think...
You know, listen if you're making a life choice like this,
there's so many things that you have to go through.
I never saw like competing for a gold medal
as a human right.
Like I just don't see it that way.
If things fall,
we don't all have the human right to be in the Olympics,
it's just not the way it is.
It's like you have to,
there are certain standards you have to meet.
So if you're changing from male to female
and you've gone through puberty as a male,
and you're trying to compete, I just don't see that,
I don't see how that's ever gonna be fair.
I don't see unless there's this body of science.
Unless you've gone through surgery or something,
I just don't see how you could ever convince me
that that's going to be fair.
And I don't know if that's just my own bias or...
And I'm not against people competing in sports.
Like I don't see age group,
if you're an age group triathlete,
more power to you go for it, doesn't concern me.
If you're a varsity athlete in high school, cool.
When you're talking about the Olympics,
I think that's where I draw the line, Olympics NCAAs.
Well, there's so many different permutations of this too.
Like what happens if you're intersex
or what happens if you...
And then like a broader discussion
about doping and just natural advantages,
like Michael Phelps's gigantic feet and hands and wingspan.
Like is that a biological advantage?
Of course it is, but that's okay.
Of course, I mean, I think we're talking a way...
These are on the extremes, right?
I know but like...
Yeah, go ahead.
Well, I'm just think that the fact
that we're trying to equate
Michael Phelps's arms and legs too,
it just shows you how kind of strange
this discussion has become,
because it's so new in the way humans
have been kind of living for so long.
And society it's so new,
we're all wrestling with how to adjust.
And sports is pretty crusty and old
like we're running through from standards
that it's not really that fluid.
It wasn't that long ago when in swimming at least
they didn't have the mile for the women
because they didn't think that women could do it
without suffering some kind of...
We're talking about like the most conservative,
sports are conservative,
I think a very conservative place.
So in terms of like society has advanced very quickly,
but then at the same time we have these issues,
like don't you remember the Koreatown spa?
There was a, a trans woman in the Koreantown spa naked
and people who were guests at the spa women didn't like it.
And then it became an issue
and then all of a sudden
the spa didn't even kick anybody out,
but it just became on the news.
And then there were protestors in front of the spa.
We're trying to figure out
the right way to operate, given inclusion.
But sports is a tough one because of its,
you know, it's conservative nature,
and because it's...
Well, because the essence of sport is fairness.
Fair play. Right?
So reconciling fair play with inclusion becomes problematic.
I mean, I do agree with you and like that idea
that on the sliding scale of how you calibrate this
at the amateur level,
at the younger level,
inclusion is much more of a priority than it becomes
as you kind of scale up into the more elite levels.
And I don't know how you solve this problem.
Obviously individual sports like swimming are one thing.
It's a different thing
when we're talking about combat sports
and people can actually get injured.
That's a whole other sticky wicket.
What I will say is I don't like how
this particular scenario with Lia
has become this political hot potato
that is now paving the way for states to pass laws,
banning trans kids from competing on sports teams.
100%
Which is, you know,
we're talking about sports teams
where inclusion should be the priority, right?
So the weaponization of this is really unsettling to me.
But at the elite level,
when we're talking about the NCAA championships
or the Olympics or whatnot,
I think we have a long way to go
to figure out how to solve this.
Perhaps there's something about rethinking
how we categorize these things all together.
In boxing, we have weight classes, right?
Is there something that we could be doing for other sports
that would solve the inclusion problem
and also ensure fairness for all?
And again, I don't have a solution for that.
You're saying like a trans division in the Olympics?
Yeah, but even that's problematic.
You know, so I'm not saying that that's the solution,
but I think we need to get creative.
And I don't know. This one's really hard.
I'm with you. I think that,
like the fact these politicians are passing,
10 states have passed laws banning trans kids competing
is a runway to unnecessary suicides.
You know, like you're gonna have kids
who take their own lives
because they feel people look at them in a certain way,
and they feel like they don't have the same possibilities.
And that is just reprehensible.
There is a Republican governor in Utah that tried to,
he did veto a law that came through like this
and they overwrote his veto.
So you're talking about out a group of people
that are really just bullying people
who are trying to figure out who they are.
And that does not sit well with me.
And it's just rooted in fear.
Yeah.
Really.
I do think there is this,
the fear of will someone claim to be trans
and go through the hormones to win a gold medal?
I definitely think there's people that could do that.
I think there are humans that could do that.
That would do that for a gold medal. I do.
I think that that exists, but...
I guess it exists,
I don't see that being a rampant thing
or something that we need
to really overly concern ourselves with.
And I also think that this situation with Lia
is relatively unique because at least in swimming,
it's the first instance
in which somebody who was actually quite good
at their sport made that transition,
which creates, this is why
this is such an inflamed situation.
There's an interesting article in the "Independent"
that takes a counterpoint on this.
On the data?
Well, basically argues
that Lia didn't have this unfair advantage.
And kind of goes into the time differences,
like during this period of transition,
there was like a year and a half when she didn't compete
because they were undergoing
that hormone therapy and it was COVID
and there were no competitions.
Like they make an interesting an argument,
but I think I'm not saying it's right or wrong,
I just think that it goes to this issue
of it being more complicated
and nuanced than just pouncing on
this is a hundred percent unfair
because this is a man competing in women's sports
or the alternative, which is,
they followed the rules, so why is everybody so upset?
Right I'm with you.
There is one trans athlete in elite athletics
that I wanted to just shine a light on really quickly
and born female,
and is now non-binary named Quinn.
Canadian soccer, women's soccer team member.
Grew up playing soccer in girls and in women's,
was a collegiate soccer player at Duke,
became not identified as non-binary sometime before
the Olympics and was on the Canadian Olympic team
that won gold medal in Tokyo.
But hormone therapy?
No hormone therapy because born female.
So the Olympic rules are,
if you are male and are transitioning to female,
you have to go through hormone...
You have to get those testosterone levels down.
If you are born female,
you can compete in men's sports anytime you want,
the question you're asking,
did Quinn take testosterone prior to going to Tokyo?
I'm not sure, but it doesn't seems so in what I read.
I really wanna get this right
and understand it to the best of my ability,
but it's tough.
And I'm 55 years old,
like this is all new and, you know...
Yeah, to us, it's new.
Yeah, to us it's new, right?
Not to date our ourselves.
It's a tough one.
We're rolling with it.
And I find myself, you know I'm somebody who always,
kind of lives in the gray.
And I can sympathize with both sides of this argument.
It's a really tricky one to solve.
I think that really, when it comes down to is
when you're talking about inclusion,
the reason some people are upset
is you wanna create the space for inclusion in all sports.
When you get to the elite levels,
Lia being allowed to compete takes somebody else
from being able to go to the finals, the NCAA finals.
And that's probably where the angst comes in.
I'm not saying, we should be anxious about it.
And it's understandable.
Right. But I do get it.
Nancy Hogshead-Makar,
Nancy Hogshead won three gold medals in the '80s swimming.
She was a superstar.
She's now a lawyer who's been very active in "Title IX,"
and women in sports issues.
And she has been very out spoken
and taking a pretty hard stand on this.
And to see it's controversial.
Siding with the women, saying this is unfair.
And kind of recruiting people to sign petitions
and do all sorts of stuff.
And she's taken a lot of flack for that,
for her pretty uncompromised position on this.
And so her perspective is like fairness
is more important than inclusion at this level.
The other argument being like,
"We have to make a place for everybody on some level,
but how do we do that and make sure that it's fair?"
Well, I think that like...
This whole idea of fairness has its limits
because inclusion is important at the level of,
but as you go up in tier into...
You mean inclusion as its limits, not fairness.
Inclusion has its limits when you get to the elite, right?
People are cut all the time from teams,
you should be allowed to compete,
and then there's a point where you get at to an elite level
and it has to be based on some rules and fairness.
I mean, I think.
So, I kind of side with kind of a gray sliding scale,
but I'd like to see the fact that politicians
are getting involved in trying to cut this off
at like the 10-year-old level,
12-year-old is reprehensible.
We can agree on that.
Yeah.
And we're not gonna solve this problem today.
Thankfully, we don't have to.
We don't.
We could just talk about it on Mondays.
I know. All right. Well, why don't we take a quick break?
I'm gonna put links up to a bunch of articles about Lia
in the show notes because...
You guys Should read it because it isn't,
it is a lot more...
It's more than what you see on social media.
A lot more nuanced, a lot more nuanced.
That's the main thing I want to get across.
Yeah, a lot more nuanced.
And it is important to try to open our minds to.
Yeah, for sure.
All right, take a quick break.
And we'll be back with the Rollies.
Prophets walk among us.
As a writer and podcaster for nearly 10 years,
I've become more convinced than ever
that our world is populated by scores of beautiful
and brilliant people who have amazing stories to share.
Those that we don't know
who can teach us something new and leave us all the better
for the experience of their sharing.
And so I've dedicated my career to tracking down
the most compelling profits on the planet,
going deep with each of them on my podcast
to elucidate the best of what they have to offer
and to sharing the insights gleaned for the benefit of all.
But the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories,
which is why I'm proud to announce the release
of my new book, "Voicing Change" volume II.
More than mere words on paper,
"Voicing Change" is a physical manifestation of the magic,
inspiration and timeless wisdom that transpires each week
on the "Rich Roll" podcast.
The first edition of "Voicing Change"
was a beautifully rendered book worthy of display
on any coffee table.
And volume two follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite conversations
in an elegant publication replete with interview excerpts,
essays, and stunning photography,
making for an exquisite companion
to the first volume or a satisfying standalone work.
And every copy comes with a chance
of winning our golden tickets sweep steaks,
six golden tickets will be hidden within a handful of books
and will unlock a treasure chest
of cool gifts donated by several of our sponsors.
See official rules for details.
Picking up this book allows you to revisit the wisdom
of your favorite everyday prophets
and physically interact
with the life changing ideas contained with it.
"Voicing Change" volume II available now
while supplies last for a limited time.
Order your copy today only at richroll.com.
All right, we're back just to put a button
on the Lia Thomas discussion,
we were talking during the break about the importance
for injecting nuance into these conversations.
And Adam, you made the point
about just the need to disabuse people
of these really like convinced takes
that everybody has on everything.
That they are absolutely right
and they come down on one side or the other side,
because I was sort of saying,
"Do we handle that appropriately?"
Like I don't feel like I really managed to articulate
a succinct position on this,
but because I don't know the answer to it.
And is that valuable or not valuable?
I think in this day and age,
the big problem we have is,
everyone's so political
and so sure of their political position.
I remember in the '90s when I first became an activist,
I was the most political person I knew.
And I thought that was a good thing.
And I think it was at the time
because there were certain things
that I felt strongly about and I wanted to help.
Now the problem is everyone is more political
than I was in the '90s.
And the thing I didn't really realize then,
which I now realize is when you're political,
even if it's for the common good,
you're kind of inherently a little bit of an asshole,
because you're not trying to harmonize,
you are trying to influence.
And that takes a certain bit of hardheadedness
and a certain amount of being so sure of yourself.
And I'm using asshole obviously as a joke,
but it is kind of that way.
Now we have a world where people
are so sure of their positions that nobody's listening.
We live in a world of assholes, Rich.
Well, certainty definitely takes the cake
in terms of trying to get audience capture
and attract people to your position
so that you can further whatever cause it is
that's important to you.
And we have lost sight or appreciation
for the nuance and the gray
and this is a topic
that is just brimming over with gray, I think.
You say it so much more eloquent than even I say it.
I don't know.
I feel like you just said exactly what I would've said.
I think you said what I would've said.
Enough, we're done with this.
We are gonna do the Rollies.
The Rollies.
The Rollies is the first inaugural award show
on this podcast, I'm pretty excited about it.
It is inspired by the Oscars.
Today is Monday, yesterday was the Oscars,
our original sort of take on it,
was F the Oscars because we're doing the Rollies,
and then insanity broke loose,
and this cultural moment occurred
that I feel like we have to talk about
because it just happened.
Of course, this podcast will not publish until Thursday,
at which point there will have been
a billion takes on this subject matter.
And perhaps people are already overly fatigued
of even talking about it.
But of course, what we're referring to
is the Will Smith-Chris Rock incident,
Will Smith walking on stage
in the middle of the Oscar's live telecast
and slapping Chris Rock across the face
in response to a joke that Chris Rock made
about Will's wife, Jada's shaved head.
I have to assume that Chris Rock was not aware
that Jada is suffering from alopecia.
We can grant him that, I think.
You're gonna grant that?
But this is such a strange cultural moment.
It was so odd.
Like it's so surreal
that this even occurred.
Were you watching the Oscars?
I was watching it.
And anybody who watched the live telecast,
realized that there was like a,
when this was going down, you saw the slap,
and then there was a glitch
and the sound went out on the telecast.
And then there was like a hard cut,
you could see Will Smith
and you could see him mouthing words,
you couldn't hear what he was saying.
The sound picks back up with Chris Rock basically saying,
"Well, that was crazy.
Like perhaps the greatest moment in television history,"
and then proceeds to introduce the documentary award,
leaving us to think that it was a scripted gag
because that's kind of what it looked like.
And I thought that that was the case
until much later in the telecast,
when of course we're on our phones and I'm with my kids
and we're scrolling through social media,
and it becomes evident that that was not a scripted thing
that this actually happened,
he actually slapped him,
and then of course you could hear the audio
from the telecast in Australia and Japan
that were being shared on social media
where you could hear what will Smith had to say
and it was rather shocking.
I don't even know where to begin with trying
to understand what's going on here.
And then of course for Will Smith to then win Best Actor,
get up and give this strange speech.
Is this the biggest celebrity meltdown
in the history of Hollywood?
Like what is happening?
On-air meltdown?
And it is kind of like
a newsroom on-air meltdown flavor to it, right?
Well, I mean the sheer magnitude of perhaps
the most beloved A list celebrity in the world,
doing something like this is unthinkable.
It's bizarre.
I know. Right.
And I'm still wrapping my head around it.
Like, again, it'll be Thursday when this goes up
and everybody will have kind of settled
into how they feel about all this,
but I'm still like trying to wrap my head around.
My brain is melting over this happening.
Okay, so here's a question.
Is it shiverish to stick up for Jada in that moment?
Yes, but violence is not the solution.
So I think the solution would have been,
well here, first of all, here's what happened.
Chris Rock tells this joke,
the GI Jane 2 joke.
Yeah. By the can I stop you there for a second?
Nobody even fucking heard of GI Jane at this point.
Like you have to be old to even come up
with that idea as a joke.
Well, I know what that joke is of course.
And they're old enough to know that joke.
It's Demi Moore with the shaved head.
So that makes you wonder,
was Chris Rock free associating,
because it's his age group,
it's his pop cultural moment
that when Demi Moore shaved her head
and became GI Jane and that was a big deal
in the, I guess early '90s, was it when that happened?
She was like the beautiful A-list star of the moment.
And she shaved her head and became GI Jane.
Like that's what he's joking about.
But anyone under the age of 40 has no fucking clue
what GI Jane is.
Maybe not, but that's neither here nor there, like...
No, the question and my point is,
was that written for him or did he free associate?
Because that does matter.
Right? Who knows?
You know, I don't know the answer to that.
Maybe that will come out in the days intervening
between when we're recording and when this gets released.
But I think the point is, how do you respond in that moment?
And so the camera cuts to Will Smith.
He actually laughs at the joke.
You could see Jada who looks not too happy about this joke.
So I suspect maybe Will then looked at his wife,
realized she was unhappy and felt some compulsion
to write this wrong or do something about it.
If he were to walk on stage
and had he, instead of slapping Chris Rock
asked for the microphone and said,
"Listen, that was inappropriate.
And I don't think that she deserves that
nor does anybody deserve to be talked to that way
or something like that."
He could have walked off like a hero.
But I think resorting to violence
is never the solution to this,
and to do it on live television in front of tens,
or if not hundreds of millions of people live
on the evening that is meant
to be perhaps your most celebrated ever
because everybody knows
that you're gonna win best actor for "King Richard."
It's just strange because he's somebody
who has built his career on being very intentional
about how he interacts with the public.
It just seems like a slip or a mishap
that would never occur.
Well, he sucker slapped somebody.
I mean clearly...
He wasn't even a fair situation.
He became overcome with emotion.
He was completely out of control,
which is so uncharacteristic for him.
The shouting was even weirder.
I found the shouting to be even weirder.
Yeah, yeah, I mean, that was where
the real violent urge came out.
Like the slap you think, okay,
he's gonna go up there and slap him
and then he's gonna chill out,
but that's not what happened.
And then his speech,
which is sort of being characterized
at least on Monday morning as an apology,
I mean, he didn't apologize to Chris rock
and he talks about,
the pain of enduring criticism
being a celebrity over all of these years,
and then proceeds to talk about being put on the planet
to spread love and be this protector,
and then drawing a comparison to his impulse
to protect his family and his wife
to that of Richard Williams was very strange.
And I don't know if you saw this,
because you didn't watch the telecast, right?
Like they cut to the William sisters in the crowd,
in the audience, and they're sitting there clearly,
not sure about how to sort of hold themselves or look like.
Well, that's where my mind went right away,
because I was watching...
They looked pretty uncomfortable to me.
Yeah, I was watching "Bad Vegan"
to prepare for this podcast that we're doing right now.
Because the Oscars have lost their luster for me
and I wasn't even watching it,
although I did see "King Richard,"
which I actually quite enjoyed,
and I got the text that were coming in
and I saw the stuff, we went on
and we watched the video and all of that.
But the thing that I immediately thought of
was poor Venus and Serena
because at the LA Critics Choice Awards or whatever it was,
or the Critics Choice Awards not the LA,
the Critics Choice Awards
when Jane Campion made her comment
about how like she has it harder than the Williams sisters,
because she competes against men.
Do you remember that comment?
Bringing them into her speech
in a way that was uninvited and I think cruel,
and dismissive of these two all time greats.
And then you have this, the Oscars.
And then this is another moment for them to be at the Oscars
and to be celebrated
and they have to deal with this bullshit.
I mean, to me it's like,
it just draws the line between sports and Hollywood,
and a lot of people like to mix them together.
The funny part about this whole thing
is when it comes to these awards
and like they're completely subjective.
It's not an objective victory,
like a Grand Slam championship.
And so to me it diminished everything.
It really pulled the veil back on what this really is,
which is just a bunch of people sitting in a room,
pretending that these winners are actually winners
when they're just popularity contests and some bullshit.
Right, or that it's even really important.
Yeah right. Exactly. Yeah.
But I still can't get over how surreal
the whole thing was.
Surreal. And also this comparison to Rich Williams.
I mean, the thing that's so absurd
is that Rich Williams would never do that
in a fucking million years.
That's the thing, right?
And had he done something like that,
it would've destroyed everything
that he was working towards for his daughters.
So that's a tough pill to swallow
if you're the Venus sister sitting in the audience,
watching this whole thing.
Yeah. The Williams sister, sorry.
And just will Smith being this person
who is known for being measured his whole career.
Yeah. Clearly.
And kind of a self-help grew personality on YouTube
and the likes...
He is a YouTuber.
I think this could be his dissent to the black hat YouTuber
that he always wanted to be.
He might be trying to angle for a Jake Paul fight.
He could be Jake Paul's next fight.
Well, one thing for sure.
It's gonna be interesting to see like how this plays out
in the intervening days.
Like if you're on his publicity team
doing crisis management right now,
what advice are you giving him?
Like is there gonna be an apology tour?
Like how is this gonna play out?
You wanna ask me my advice, if I was on there?
Here's my advice.
What is your advice as a professional flack.
Will, Will, Will, show great concern and do nothing.
Meaning just don't comment on it?
Don't comment.
Don't go on the talk shows.
(Adam speaking Spanish)
And just see how, see what happens.
Lay low. Yeah.
Chris Rock on the other hand,
needs to give an interview.
I listened to Bill Simmons and Jimmy Kimmel,
were breaking this down on Bill Simmons' podcast.
And Kimmel that Will Smith declined to be on the show,
but who he really wanted to talk to is Chris Rock
to get his perspective on this whole thing?
I mean, Chris Rock having to react to this in real time,
looking clearly flustered at what had just transpired.
I felt for him, he was actually a pro.
Yeah. At the same time.
I mean, clearly the awards cast
was taking a bit like sort of a light version
of what Ricky Gervais does,
because they were making fun of the celebrities.
And kind of taking the piss out of them,
which is fine on some level,
but clearly in Will Smith's mind,
a line was crossed that he didn't appreciate.
And there were some other kind of tasteless stuff
that was going on throughout the evening
and you can argue about whether it was funny or not,
but the manner in which
he decided to handle this was not okay.
Well, you do wonder if there's some bad blood between them
because Chris Rock joked about Jada six years ago in 2016
on the Oscar stage about, because I guess...
They had boycotted that year.
The had boycotted the Oscars,
because all the acting nominees were white.
And then Chris Rock made the joke that Jada is on a TV show.
So that's like, you know, she wasn't invited.
She wouldn't have been invited anyway.
So he made a more tasteless joke.
And so maybe there's like this bad blood.
Maybe they're just really not funny people
and they're worth half a billion dollars,
whatever they're worth.
And they feel like they should be worshiped
and not ridiculed.
And in my book, if you're worth half a billion dollars
or anywhere close to that, you deserve to be ridiculed.
And that's just part of your position
and that's what the money is for.
And it's like, you know, bottom line is this.
You are wealthy, you are powerful,
you're the top dog in Hollywood.
Awesome. I loved what's the zombie movie?
Oh the one where he is standing on the...
In Manhattan by himself.
Yeah. I know he's on the battleship
or the aircraft carrier hitting golf balls?
Yeah, that one.
Yeah, I forget what it's called.
That one I loved.
And I really liked "King Richard,"
but the bottom line is, you're not entitled
to walk through life not made fun of.
This is the way it is.
And if you're like,
you've been through the ringer for a long time time,
this is your big night.
I mean, obviously you weren't handling your big night well,
you were emotionally overwrought, you weren't chill.
And you should have been more chill.
So that's my take on it.
I mean, like, it is bizarre.
It does make you wonder about where his state of mind is
and all of that.
Do you think he recovers and that everybody just moves on
and forgets about this?
Of course he recovers, he's bankable.
You know, what you wonder is,
he has a big book out, he did a book.
He collaborated with a...
Sure with Mark Manson.
Yeah with a sale art guy and they've got it
into the top five on Amazon.
And does his book sales go up?
Do they go down?
Probably go up. Right?
I don't know.
Interesting.
We shall see, but yeah.
Fascinating, like just unbelievable that that occurred.
It's crazy.
By the way, was that happening while Sean Penn
was smelting his Oscars or did it happen before?
Did Sean Penn not smelt?
As far as I know,
he has not yet smelted them because he said
that he would smelt them publicly.
So I assume that there will be some kind of live cast
or something like that.
But listen, shout out to Sean Penn,
whatever you think of this guy,
like he walks his talk, like he's in Poland.
And he was in the Ukraine.
He was.
Boots on the ground.
Taking a stand saying if Zelensky,
if they don't let Zelensky do a live stream
into the Oscars telecast
that he will personally melt down his Oscars,
smelt down, it was the word that he was used.
He used the word smelt.
Is he going to self-smelt?
I don't know, but...
He is the type of guy that self smelts.
I respect his hardcore stance on this.
Me too.
I mean the Oscars was never gonna let Zelensky beam in,
to the middle of this.
That was never gonna happen.
But I'll respect him even more if he self smelts.
I don't want him to hire a smelter.
Like it would be so Hollywood,
if he hired like the greatest smelter.
Yeah, but smelting
at home probably isn't a wise or safe practice.
It doesn't have to be home.
You need a facility for smelting.
You know what he should do.
How hot does it have
to get to melt that thing down?
He needs to rent the Kodak theater and smelt it on stage.
Smelt it on stage, yeah.
Well, I look forward to whatever media circus
is gonna squirrel around that public smelting.
It's possible nobody shows up.
I don't know.
You think there'll be a lot of smelters?
I would show up for that.
I wanna see him do that.
Listeners, we're gonna livestream from the smelting, Pam.
From wherever that transpires who knows.
All right, we're gonna get off the Oscars,
but final thing before we do so.
Friend of the pod, Lindsay Krause,
walked home with an Oscar,
the queen of basketball was in New York times Op-Doc
that she was a producer on,
so congratulations to Lindsay.
Congratulations to Lindsay.
And Steph Curry and Shaq were also producers.
Yeah, that's true.
Pretty well.
It's pretty cool.
And I feel bad for Questlove who had to go up
and accept his documentary award
right after the whole thing.
Right, that sucked.
His movie is phenomenal.
I Know.
Yeah.
"Summer of Soul." Is the movie.
Congrats to Questlove.
All right, so we're gonna move on to the Rollies.
There's a lot of talk in the world of content creation
about audience capture.
For those that don't know,
audience capture is when you configure your content
to kind of give the audience what you think they want,
like you look at your metrics and you're like,
"Oh, when I do this controversial thing
or I take this hard stand,
or I have this person on as a guest,
I get more views and more attention.
So I will do more of that
so that I will get more audience."
Well, what we're doing here today,
I would say is quite perhaps the opposite of that.
Nobody wants this you are saying?
I don't know that they do.
(Adam laughing)
So whatever the opposite of audience capture is,
that is maybe what the Rollies are.
But the Rollies.
And this was your idea by the way.
This was my idea.
I soft pedaled this pitch last "Roll On," two weeks ago.
And tried to get you to commit
to some categories pretty much right away.
But we finally cobbled together our categories.
Right, so who knows whether this will work or not,
but essentially the idea is in the spirit of the Oscars,
if we were gonna do our own award show here on the RRP,
what would that look like?
What would the categories be?
And this is what we've come up with for better or worse.
Some categories might be more interest than others,
but what we're gonna do is we're gonna go through
the categories and the nominees,
and we're gonna have a link in the show notes
or in the description below if you're watching on YouTube,
that you will be able to click on that will pull up
like a Google form where you,
the on audience members can vote.
And next "Roll On" we will announce the winners.
How does that sound?
This is great.
Kick us off with the first category.
I feel like we should have some kind of music cue
that plays in.
(lively orchestral music)
All right. Ready?
Yeah.
We're starting with a, just like in true Oscar's form.
We're coming out hot with best endurance performance
in an RRP supporting role.
Nominees are, Davy.
(both laughing)
Multiple marathons and trail races.
He went from zero to a goddamn good runner.
Right, so this is a guy
who literally hadn't run ever before.
And in a year's time has suddenly become
one of the bigger running enthusiasts
you're ever gonna meet.
He started a running shoe collection
that would rival any professional runner at this point
and is obsessed, he even created his own Instagram account
just for his running, "Davy Runs".
Which lands him in good stead as the first nominee.
Who else is nominated?
A sub for our marathon,
would've been even faster if he hadn't had a knee injury,
he ran through a knee injury.
Correct. Big sir, on the horizon
and New York city marathon, right?
Coming up.
And he ran that trail race with
the other two nominees coming up.
Blake, first ultra great performance in the pool as well.
Diversity.
Yes, he's on his way to becoming
the next great swim runner.
Right, so Otilow is next for Blake, he's been in the pool.
He runs, he does it all.
You know Blake, you love him,
he's the guy behind the video camera here today.
Davy is our photographer for those who are new.
So yeah Blake in good stead.
Jason, his run streak is close to 300 days now.
The Malibu half, multiple trail races.
He's done the four by four by 48 twice.
He is the king of consistency.
This is not new for Jason.
Unlike Davy, Jason has been living
this lifestyle for a long time so he gets kudos for that.
Oh, wow. That sounds like a...
Never misses a day.
Tackled many in adventure out there, too many to list.
He's also the longest standing team member of the podcast.
Not that that plays into
the endurance performance piece here,
but to be an endurance athlete,
you gotta go the distance, right?
Jason has gone the distance.
Sounds like someone's already decided who he's voting for.
I'm just giving some context for people that don't know.
Jason is our longtime audio engineer,
and now kind of producer at large.
And he has run a hundred milers.
He has.
And then the last nominee as we go down the list of talent
from top to bottom, and I do mean the bottom.
These are in no particular order, but go ahead.
Adam, I think that's me.
Alcatraz swimmer and if you remember,
he finished with a flourish
by circling multiple sailboats in the harbor.
Malibu, half marathon, two times four by four by 48.
Swims with sharks, he swims with whales.
He doesn't swim fast, but he swims.
There's a little embellishment here.
I mean, this is just not right.
You came up with this category
and you included yourself as a nominee?
Wait that was me who wrote this?
Yeah.
Oh.
Come on.
Wait, am I allowed to be in this list?
You may be, look you're the on camera on mic talent.
People know who you are.
Unlike some with the behind the scenes talent here.
But on the subject of self-mythologizing,
which we're gonna get into here,
this is proof, evidence that you are not immune
from cultivating your own image in furtherance
of the American dream.
Of one day winning a Rollie.
I'm not saying vote for me,
but what I'm saying is, vote for me.
A vote for me is a vote for you.
All right, so there you go,
Davy, Blake, Jason and Adam,
nominees for best endurance performance
in an RRP supporting role.
And yes, like the Oscars,
we come out of the gate with a supporting role award
because that's how they do it there.
I will say that of the four,
I am the worst athlete, if that helps.
Oh, now you say.
Yeah. I will say based on the data.
Was that some kind of reverse psychology
that you're gonna play.
No, based on the Strava data it's pretty obvious.
All right. Next category.
Moving along.
Best endurance performance of the year
by an RRP guest.
So we talked about how many nominees
there should be for each category.
I think you originally proposed three,
but fuck it we have a bunch here
and that's just the way it is.
We got Hellah Sidibe,
who of course ran across United States.
We got Robbie Ballinger, who we were talking about earlier.
Set the Central Park loop record.
Also did this California crush where he...
Colorado crush.
Colorado crush. That's what I mean.
Colorado crush, 52 fourteeners.
And finished with the Leadville 100 I think. Right?
We have the great Courtney DeWalt who just won everything
basically a ton of stuff, it's really not even fair.
Didn't she also set the 100 mile record for women?
I think she did.
No, not on like the road or the track.
that I'm aware of.
I can't keep up with her.
She's basically won.
She's the GOAT, right?
She is the GOAT. Right?
But then we have Harvey Lewis, recent podcast guest.
He ran 354 miles in the Big Dog's Backyard Ultra.
Holy cow.
We have Lea Goldstein who won Ramp first female victor
in the cycling race, Race Cross America.
Then we have the Iron Cowboy
who did 101 consecutive iron distance triathlons.
We were there with him.
We were.
Was quite a day.
Timothy Olson who ran the Pacific Coast Trail.
Pacific Crest Trail.
He had that FKT.
Yeah he got the FKT,
fasted person to run the PCT, FKT in the PCT.
He did the FKT in the PCT baby, Timothy Olson.
Two more, we got Lewis Pugh who swam in the Arctic circle.
Yes, he swam in the Arctic
to raise awareness of climate change in Greenland.
Popped into a roll on by Zoom
from South Africa to share about that.
And final nominee, Jason Caldwell for his Pacific row.
Rode across the Pacific from...
Fasted, crushed the record.
Right, was this from San Francisco to Hawaii?
Yeah, so Hellah Sidibe, Robbie Ballinger,
Courtney DeWalt, Harvey Lewis,
Lea Goldstein, Iron cowboy, Timothy Olson,
Lewis Pugh and Jason Caldwell.
That's a hell of a list.
It is, that's a lot of nominees.
It is.
I'm sure I left people off too who are deserving.
See, that's how you do a list without favoritism Rich,
just in the future.
Just include as many, just include all of them.
No, the previous nomination list,
your favoritism really came out.
Right.
Is my point.
Here's an interesting category that we have,
coolest person of 2021.
Who do we have?
Jonny Greenwood.
Let me talk about him
because that was my addition to these nominations.
You're the Jonny Greenwood guy.
Yeah. Jonny Greenwood.
You guys know who Jonny Greenwood is, right?
Radiohead lead guitarist, keyboardist, turned film composer.
So this guy, this is incredible.
This Is like Danny Elfman 2.0.
Even better, his music is extraordinary.
In the past he has scored, "There Will be Blood,"
"The Master," "Inherent vice," "Phantom Thread."
Clearly he's Paul Thomas Anderson's favorite.
And this year alone,
he wrote the film scores for "Spencer,"
"Power of the Dog" and "Licorice Pizza."
Which is pretty incredible.
While also being in the coolest band in the world.
It's unbelievable.
Are they still the coolest band in the world?
I mean, if you ask me, they are.
I don't know. It depends on who you talk to.
But you know we're a couple of old men.
I don't know what's going on.
What about your kids?
Well, for my boys?
Yeah.
Radiohead is king.
Yeah. And will always be king.
Fair enough.
Jonny Greenwood, actually this year
ended up doing a fair amount of press like campaigning
because he was nominated for an Oscar
for his score for "Power of the Dog."
And it was super interesting.
These interviews him about his process,
of how he thinks about writing music
and how he scores these things.
And with "Power of the Dog,"
the idea was to create music that was somewhat haunting
and foreboding while also being true
to the sort of tropes of a Western.
And he wanted that like banjo sound,
but he wanted it to sound like more like suspenseful.
So a lot of the score is him playing essentially
the way you would play a banjo,
but playing it on a bass, like a cello.
And if you go back and listen to the music,
it's very unique and cool.
So anyway, I just find that to be fascinating.
And so that's why he is...
Did you watch "Power of the Dog?"
Yeah. I love that movie. Only got one Oscar.
Jane Campion won for best director,
but got shut out by "CODA,"
in a lot of the other categories.
Did you watch "CODA?"
I have not seen "CODA."
Me neither.
All right why don't you hit me with the next nominee?
So this nominee really probably belongs
to the coolest person of 2022,
but you had said, you know, whatever,
keep them in there, Rafael Nadal.
Rafael Nadal. You're obsessed with Rafael Nadal.
I'm a late comer obsessed with Rafael Nadal.
Rafael Nadal, for those who live under a rock
is one of the greatest tennis players of all time.
He has the record for 21 Grand Slam titles.
He tied Roger's record and then Novak Djokovich tied that.
So the three of them held it together.
And then Novak was set to basically,
he was in the U.S. open final,
and he could have had the record for himself
and no one ever considers Rafael Nadal really
because a lot of his titles came for the French open.
Roger was always the greatest Rafael was right there.
And then when Novak started to take over,
everyone just considered,
"Oh, we all have to now agree that Novak Djokovic,
who's kind of this insufferable."
A strange view, he has strange views.
He wouldn't take the vaccine.
I'm not judging anybody.
I'm just saying he wouldn't take it.
And because of that he couldn't compete
in some of these Grand Slams that just happened.
But even before that,
he's just been this lightning rod for a number of reasons.
And no one really liked him that much he'd get booed a lot.
Even at the titles, he was winning Novak Djokovic.
And then in the U.S. open something magical happened,
everyone loved him, we were all content to say,
okay, he is the greatest, but then he lost.
And then this year in the Australian open,
coming off injury, Rafael Nadal won the 21st Grand Slam.
Novak wouldn't compete because he wouldn't take the vaccine.
They wouldn't let him in,
there was a big high profile thing
where they almost let him in
and then they didn't let him in.
And when Rafael won it, no one thought he'd win it
because he had been hurt, he hadn't been playing.
And I think there was this like sigh of relief
in the tennis world
and everyone just like loved Rafael
because they didn't have
to admit that Nova was the best anymore.
And so the tennis world just loves this guy.
I happen to just see him in Indian Wells
and the place was just wild for him.
I mean like everywhere he went,
every match he was in sold out.
He's a full on rockstar but what I love about him,
isn't just that he's a great tennis player.
It's that when he loses,
he always talks about going back to practice.
He's always said the right thing.
He never blames any circumstances
or injuries for his losses.
He's never a baby about the rules.
He's always a straight shooter.
And not only that,
he takes the corniest sight seeing pictures ever,
if you go on his Instagram,
you could see him riding a bike
with a goofy helmet around DC, taking pictures of himself
in front of the Lincoln Memorial.
Watching the monument and like really funny like dad,
like very Griswoldy and tourist photos.
And so I think all that all together.
And not slapping anyone.
He never slaps anyone.
He's like the most humble,
hardworking grittiest guy,
never was considered the greatest,
you know Roger was the greatest and then was Novak,
and now it really might be Rafael
and I think that's a beautiful thing.
Case well stated.
Thank you.
All right. Next nominee.
Somebody whose name has come up on this show in the past.
Bo Burnham.
He did make, what I think is
the most groundbreaking special of the last year.
I just love "Inside," his one-man show.
And I also love the fact that as soon as he made it
and released it, he just ghosted everybody
and didn't do any press.
And you know, he would once in a while,
like put up an Instagram post
just to say like a song was available
or when it went on streaming or whatever,
but he did to my mind,
unless I'm not aware like no interviews over this at all,
just put it up there and true
to the kind of themes of that special,
just went back to living his life I suspect.
So there's something kind of ballsy and cool about.
A hundred percent.
"Smooth" is the best comedy hour that I saw in many years.
Yeah, I think one of the greatest pieces of comedy
I've ever seen and it goes on the list
with like "Live of the Sunset Strip," Richard Pryor,
"Delirious," you know, "Baby Cole Rally..."
I mean, whatever I'm mentioning,
there's been a lot of great ones,
but this is definitely on that list.
Wouldn't you say?
I Would for sure.
Next nominee Nimsdai Purja.
Nimsdai Purja.
Nimsdai is that how you say it?
He just goes by Nims though.
He goes by Nims.
Nims is this year had a big hit
with 14 peaks on Netflix's documentary
about breaking the record for all 14,
8,000 meter peaks in the Himalayas.
He broke a record that was at seven years
or something and it was the great, what is it?
I'm spacing on the great climber that had the record.
I think it was,
I don't know the name.
Messner. I think it was Rudolph Messner, pretty sure.
And he broke the record and he did it in six months
and he's Nepalese.
And so the idea, of course, that release comes on the heels
of him leading a team of Nepalese climbers
to the winter summit of K2 first ever to do that.
Yeah, first people that ever summit K2 in the winter time.
Yeah that was January 2021.
I was lucky enough to be able to cover that.
And Nims, then he had 14 peaks come on after that,
that became one of the biggest hits on the streaming.
Yeah, and it really goes into his back story
and you meet his wife and you see his commitment to...
all the way up there's scenes where he's holding
a climber who might be dying on the slopes,
and just his commitment to his team
and his climbers and to working hard.
He's like a Rafa type and like a Goggins type,
like that kind of grit.
Earned and deserved his spot in the nominees,
the Rollie nominees of coolest people in 2021.
And our last Rollie nominee is?
Billie Eilish.
Yes.
Won the Oscar along with her brother Finneas last night
for writing and performing the bond theme song.
"No time to Die."
So how old is she now?
I mean, she's so young.
Let's see.
And she just absolutely dominates the music industry.
And now is an Oscar winner dominated the Grammy's,
dominates the Oscars,
put in an incredible performance last night,
and just has so much life ahead of her.
And I just think she's super cool.
I don't know how old she is.
25 maybe.
I think that's light, I think she's younger.
Younger?
Yeah.
23. Somebody can find out.
But anyway it was really cool
to see her perform last night and yeah...
20.
Get out.
That's what it says.
She's only 20?
Born December 8th, 2001.
That's crazy.
How many Grammys does she have?
Let's see, we are aware that most of these nominees
are men and we have Billie Eilish, a woman,
but Billie Eilish is a huge superstar in our defense.
So we came up with a good list, I think here.
While you're looking up, how many Grammys she has,
I'm gonna launch into the next category,
which is my favorite category by far.
By six Grammys.
Six Grammys. Okay.
This next category is best limited series
about narcissistic self-mythologizing,
AKA the scammer series.
So I don't know, guys are all aware,
but there is this trend in streaming media right now
of these limited series and mini-series
that are about these amazing ascents
to power, money, and fame, and then precipitous falls.
The supernovas is the word.
Yeah basically, supernovas, right?
Like you are a supernova.
Yeah. Wink, wink, nod, nod.
And this category is just rife with so much deliciousness.
All right.
The first nominee is super pumped by friend of the pod,
Brian Koppelman and is writing
and producing partner, David Levine.
This is the story of Travis Kalanick and Uber,
if you're into great dialogue, this is fantastic.
If you enjoy "Billions," this is right up your alley.
And essentially the theme of this is the theme
that recurs throughout the other nominees
that we're gonna get to,
which is the person who has the audacious dream
and outsized ambition and a crazy amount of ego
and charisma, the sort of requirements
to manifest something massive into the world like Uber,
are also the qualities
that ultimately precipitate your decline.
They ruin you because you can't get out of your own way.
And that's the kind of recurring story motif
amongst all of these.
Does it start with him waiting for a cab that never comes?
No, there's versions of that throughout though.
You haven't watched this one yet, have you?
Well, no, because unfortunately
this is the only one I haven't seen an episode of.
And that's because I don't get the show time add on.
Get on that.
I know.
But yeah.
Sorry, Brian,
It's Joseph Gordon-Levitt plays Travis Kalanick
and you know it's fascinating to watch,
something that most of us have used, Uber,
and like how it came into being.
And how it sort of transplanted
the taxi industry completely.
Like how did that happen?
Well, it didn't happen by accident,
it happened with great will and intention
for better or worse.
There you go. And aside, what's your favorite JGL film?
What's the cancer one that he did?
"50/50." That's mine too.
I love "50/50."
Yeah, I love "50/50."
With Seth Rogan and Anna Kendrick.
She's fabulous.
Did you see "Mysterious Skin?"
The Greg or Rocky movie that he did?
Yeah. All right.
Anyway. All right. Moving along. We don't have all day here.
We crashed.
So this is the WeWork story.
Based on the podcast, "We Crashed."
I dunno what to say about this one.
I mean, this is just like...
(Adam interrupting indistinctly)
Right we do.
I mean, this one is just off the rails over the top.
I mean, Jared Leto is going full banana in this one
with like prosthetic teeth and like the accent,
the Israeli accent.
I love his Israeli accent.
Playing Adam Newman whose partners
with Miguel Mckelvey, friend of the podcast.
It's sort of surreal to watch this knowing Miguel.
Oh, you know Miguel?
Yeah, I know Miguel and would consider myself
a friend of Miguel's
and when I'm watching this, I'm like,
is this exactly how it happened?
I'm not sure, but just watching Jared Leto,
like hang dog this whole thing is so out of control.
I love it. I love him.
And Anne Hathaway, I think this is really her show.
Like her performance
is actually pretty remarkable as Rebecca.
It's a much more...
She's always great.
It's a much more nuanced performance.
Like she has these interesting ups and downs.
I don't know how many episodes in are you
at this point on this one?
Just one.
Oh yeah.
So she gets, there's a lot of meat on the bone
for Anne Hathaway in this one.
So same story, like guy with a huge ambition
and unbelievable charisma,
like wields this thing into the world against all odds.
And ultimately it's his ego that gets in the way
and precipitates his demise.
You know, it's interesting how this sort of shows up
in all these different narratives
that are about these ostensibly tech companies.
I mean, WeWork isn't really a tech company,
but it's part of that kind of Silicon Valley mindset
of being a disruptor.
It's interesting because you...
Re-imagining work.
As we go through these
and the next nominee isn't quite in the same level,
but like in terms of like how you feel
in terms of sympathy towards the main character,
I think of like "Wolf of Wall Street,"
this gold standard it's supposed
to be an expose on how bad a guy Jordan Belford is,
but you end up loving him and...
Celebrating these people and it's a weird thing.
It's sort of like,
am I supposed to be rooting for Travis Kalanick here?
You do though. Right?
Same way when you watch "Billions,"
it's like, are you supposed to be rooting
for these billionaires?
Everybody is acting terribly. Right?
But yet you root for them.
And it's sort of delicious peppered with some,
a healthy dose of schadenfreude.
I think there's something about,
and I want to get into it once we get through the nominees,
like, why is it that we're attracted to these?
Like, is it because when we see them fall,
it makes us feel better about our own lives.
It's interesting, we should get into that.
I mean, I think that this, "The Dropout,"
the Elizabeth Holmes story about Theranos.
So that's the next one, the next nominee is "The Dropout."
And then I think because
of the way Amanda Seyfried plays are
and because of the writing,
you see kind of the creepiness in the back of her mind,
like you're not feeling the sympathy I think for her
as you do these others because she's not a superwoman,
like from the beginning, you see that she's really tortured.
She not gifted with charm and charisma.
Right.
She has to develop an adaptive strategy
because she lacks that so she cultivates this weird voice
and the clothes that she's wearing to overcome
that deficit that comes naturally to Adam Newman
and to Travis Kalanick which makes it,
you know, like it's just...
Which makes it more nuance show.
I think it's more interesting.
It's much more nuance and also I think
what's different about "The Dropout" versus "WeCrashed"
and "Superpumped" is they do spend
a lot of time on her background.
So you see her at a young age moving through the world
for the better part of like an episode and a half
before we even get into Theranos.
Whereas the other shows just drop you
into those tech companies
or those companies at their inception.
So I think that helps you be a little bit more empathetic
to where she's coming from.
And I think "The Dropout" is perhaps,
at least the most artfully crafted of all of these shows,
and just a knockout performance, I think by Amanda Seyfried.
Like when she's looking into the mirror
and she's working on her voice,
like I don't know how many episodes you are in.
Yeah I know, I saw that.
It's creepy, and bizarre knowing how the story plays out,
it's unbelievable.
And we have to shout out Yurkash who has a great part
in this series as a graduate student at Stanford
who kind of ushers Elizabeth Holmes
into this graduate lab and then ultimately
becomes one of the first employees in Theranos.
He's fabulous.
He's always good.
And again, based on the podcast, "The Dropout."
So I just want you guys to know in Hollywood,
you can adapt, Roll On anytime you want.
Just let us know, give us a call.
All right. Next nominee.
"Inventing Anna."
The Anna Delvey story.
This is just straight up trash.
This is just trash.
Is the Shonda Rhimes massive hit?
It's a spectacular hit.
I know the trashiest of all of them, for sure.
Starring the actress that we grew to love on "Ozark."
She was like, she's the...
She's phenomenal.
No, she's great. What's her name?
I forget her name. I should know her name.
What's her name? Look that up.
Yeah. "Inventing Anna."
But this is perhaps the most crystallized version
of what it means to self-mythologize
because she arrives in New York,
intent upon taking over high society in...
Julia Garner.
Yeah Julia Garner.
In this quest to kind of create
this elite club for high rollers
and powerful Manhattan nights.
The Anna Delvey foundation.
(Rich laughing)
It's delicious in that regard.
And at times very hard to watch.
It's it's not a good show.
But certainly earned its place as a nominee
on the subject of self-mythologizing.
It's not a good show.
And by the way, the journalist isn't likable,
there's very few likable characters in it.
No, I would agree with that.
Her lawyer, I think is the exception he's likable.
Honorable mention.
Not a fictional take.
We're gonna spend a couple minutes on this one.
The honorable mention,
because it doesn't quite fit into the genre.
It's sort of a skew,
but I think it's still relevant.
It's a documentary series.
Which is different.
In Netflix, I think this was the number one.
I don't know if it still is,
but it was a number one show on Netflix,
and it is "Bad Vegan."
"Bad vegan."
This is the story of Sarma Melngailis.
Who was the proprietor of pure food
and wine in New York city,
which was the kind of premier raw food establishment
for many years.
I've eaten there many times.
Is it still a thing? No.
Well it's closed now because of what happened.
But I don't know.
I mean every time I would go to New York,
I would go there
and it had this beautiful back outdoor patio.
The food was marvelous and amazing.
She originally founded it with Matthew Kenny,
who she met and worked on his cookbook.
And then they worked together her for a number of years,
they split, Sarma took over the restaurant,
owed Jeffrey Chodorow, is that how you say his last name?
The restaurant tour financier guy, like $2 million.
And so was servicing that debt
as she was trying to grow this business,
and then falls under the spell
of this man who found out who, yeah Nadiwel.
Who turns out to be this unbelievable grifter.
Who victimizes her, manipulates her,
puts her through what they call "cosmic endurance tests."
And I'm not sure she's completely disabused herself
of his spell.
And that's the most interesting thing
because you haven't watched this whole thing.
No, I watched the first episode.
So I remember when this whole thing went down,
essentially Anthony Strangis,
this guy, manipulates her into giving him money.
She begins siphoning money out of the restaurant
and giving it to him for various purposes
that end up going towards sort of expensive travel
and watches and gambling and the like.
And it got so bad that she couldn't make payroll anymore.
She's trying to rationalize this,
it's a house of cards.
It falls, you know, topples on top of her.
It's a longer story and it's fascinating to watch this show
and see how it all plays out.
But she basically ends up going on the lam.
She has a different version of what actually happened,
but there's a warrant out for her arrest.
Anthony and her are hold up in a hotel room in Tennessee
where Dollywood is, in a weird hotel room.
Oh, you gotta watch the rest of this show.
It's unbelievable.
And they end up catching her
because Anthony orders a Domino's pizza
and his name was on the credit card and they flagged it.
And the cops descend on the hotel room and arrest them.
They both do jail time.
She basically built pure food and wine out of $1.6 million
that ended up in Anthony Strangis' bank account.
And the restaurant goes out of business.
And it's just the strangest thing
because she's this sort of face of raw vegan cuisine,
beautiful girl, smart, went to Wharton
and was really fated for being this big personality
in the vegan movement
and somebody who was well liked by her staff
and all of that.
So this pivot from being a rational actor
who is running a viable business
to this strange world of being under the spell
of this guy who was truly a grifter,
like how does that happen to an intelligent woman?
You wonder like how is it these really smart people
do really stupid things because it's also stuff
that like people from the outside looking in
just from the first episode
and you could see they were like,
"This guy's bad news."
Like everybody who met him immediately knew he was bad news.
And this story when it happened was perfect
for Vanity Fair and New York magazine.
So there were a lot of long reads about this at the time.
Like how could this possibly happen?
And this raw vegan queen ultimately gets toppled
by a Domino's pizza.
She was very quick to say,
I'm not the one who ordered the pizza, that was Anthony.
That was her biggest offense in some peoples minds.
What's interesting about this is the show
is that she participates in it.
So it's a docu-series in which she's basically on camera
giving her version of events.
To try to set the record straight.
And so with that,
I felt myself more sympathetic towards her
than I had just in reading these articles.
But I also have to say that after watching,
how many episodes are there? Six.
When I got to the end of it,
I really didn't feel like she had learned anything
or that she felt like,
there was like an empathy piece that was missing.
So I'm interested in how this is gonna land
when you finish watching it.
It's like she gets to the other side of it
and then she still calls up Strangis
and wants to know how he's doing.
And she understands intellectually,
she'll never be able to borrow money again,
it's unlikely she'll ever be able
to have a restaurant again,
but on some level also feels weirdly unapologetic
or not quite emotionally connected.
Like she's very robotic about the whole thing.
Which left me feeling a little bit empty
about the whole affair.
I'm sorry to interrupt.
I see a big parallel here
that I hadn't thought of until you were talking about this.
Smart people who fall under the sway of people
that should be see through to so many.
Doesn't that sound like intelligent people
that have fallen under the sway of a Qanon
or a political figure.
Or like smart people in Russia that believe Putin's lies
that they're not invading Ukraine or isn't that like,
isn't that thing, doesn't that encapsulate
so much about our current problems
in terms of information and what we believe?
Certainly there's gotta be similarities there.
I mean, I think in the case of Elizabeth Holmes
and Adam Newman and Travis Kalanick,
these people were persuasive because they were able
to espouse the ambition that they had for these companies
with a sense of like world changing purpose.
And also this idea
that it would make everybody wildly powerful and rich.
And that's what people want to hear.
So to the extent that you can charismatically deliver
a message that somebody wants to hear,
I think that is relevant to your point.
I think in the case of Sarma,
part of the Anthony Strangis message was like this idea
that like this weird cosmic thing that like you're special.
And if I'm gonna put you through these tests
and if you can get through them,
like he fed her like a bill of goods,
that's just like completely bizarre about,
"There's a plan for you
and there'll be more money than you can ever need."
Like she...
And your dog will be immortal.
You know, her culpability was
that part of how she fell under the spell of this guy
is that he was promising her great riches.
And she wanted to believe that that would be the case.
And so even when any outsider could look at this and say,
there's something terribly wrong here, he would say,
you have to stick with me, just, you know,
you gotta wire me this $10,000 and I promise you in a month,
you're gonna have everything that you want and you need,
and we're gonna make all your ambitions true
and this kept continuing until she was so deep in
that the only way out for her was to convince herself
that everything he was saying was true,
including that her dog would be immortal.
Yeah, and he had this
other life or this past
that she didn't really know anything about.
She was able to like compartmentalize that.
Black ops.
Yeah. I mean, it's just the weirdest thing.
Yeah.
That this smart, intelligent person
could be so manipulated.
So perhaps we're all more easily manipulated
than we wanna believe.
How do you think I've kept this job so long?
Like how think Oz the Mentalist was able
to get me to say things he wanted me to say.
Are you still thinking about that?
I am, I can't stop thinking about it.
(Adam laughing)
But you know, the fact that Sarma kind of gets
all the way to the other side of this
and doesn't seem to really have had
any kind of emotional growth arc
I think is one important takeaway from that.
Do you wanna get back into the Schadenfreude
or move along?
Well, I think just in terms of like all of these shows,
the meta commentary here is like,
why are these so popular right now?
Why is it that this is the kind of thing
that people like to watch?
Why are these all coming out at the same time?
And I think there's something very American about it,
this idea of self-mythologizing.
Like you can come here and you can be anybody you wanna be.
And so the incentive structure is to lie,
or elaborate, or to leverage your charisma,
to convince people of doing what you want them to do,
to kind of manifest this out sized dream.
And that can go wrong when
the house of cards falls on top of you
and the truth is revealed.
But the fact that these are popular indicates
that there's something about us that's attracted to that.
And perhaps that is
the schadenfreude of seeing powerful rich people,
collapse on top of each other.
I don't know.
Like a certain slap.
Like a certain slap. Yeah.
Like now we're all talking about Will Smith.
What's gonna happen to him?
It's the car crash that you can't turn away from.
Yeah. I suppose. I don't know.
Interesting.
All right. Let's move on.
Let's do some speed rounds through these next ones.
We don't have to get too deep into it.
Most RRP-Larp like film of 2021.
Meaning these are the films that fall
into the wheelhouse of one "Rich Roll" podcast.
Right, if this podcast was a piece
of filmed entertainment, who would be the nominees?
"The Alpinist."
Good one.
"14 Peaks."
Another good one.
"Don't Look Up."
Perfect. Of course. "Don't look up."
Wait, we're living that right now.
Yeah.
"Road Runner."
Love it.
Of course. "The Rescue."
From friends of the pod, Jimmy Chin and Chai Vasarhelyi.
"Dope Sick."
"Dope Sick," opioid crisis in the sack...
That's right.
"The Alpinist" is about the Mountaineer in Canada that...
The ice climber
The ice climber 14 peak is Nims.
So there you have it.
That's a good list.
Also, I should say we're probably missing stuff,
so audience members who are outraged right now,
because we didn't include X, Y, or Z go easy on us.
Yeah. Go easy on us.
This is the Rollies.
We're doing our best.
Did I say it that outside of this podcast
that we were gonna venture into the dunderheaded?
Yeah.
That's what we're doing.
That's where we are right now.
I watched the first three of these.
I did not yet see "Road Runner" or "The Rescue,"
which I should see.
You haven't seen "The Rescue?"
Know and I covered the Thai cave thing.
But you know what I'm waiting
there's a couple of Thai cave series coming out on Netflix.
There's the fictional one,
which is by the guys behind "Crazy Rich Asians."
And then there's also a documentary with,
this focuses on the Thai soccer team themselves,
because that's Jimmy and Chai didn't have access
to the soccer team.
But you gotta see "The Rescue."
The Thai rescue itself has spawned
like its own world of industry.
And all of those stuff and projects.
It's just, you know, some of us are raising 19-months-old.
Come on, always with the excuse.
I know that's so unruff of me.
That really is.
Next category.
Best book by an RRP guest in 2021.
This was a tough one.
Lots of books. Lots of great guests.
You know, I love all my guests.
You know, I love all their books.
I wouldn't have them on the podcast otherwise.
So lots of nominees here.
And if your favorite isn't on this list, I get it.
I didn't want to take anybody off this list,
but here's what we came up with.
First nominee "Bravey" by Alexi PaaS.
And we have "Think Again" by Adam Grant,
"Why we Sleep" by Matthew Walker.
Although that book was written a couple years ago,
even though know Matthew was on the podcast last year.
So what are the rules here?
There are no rules, it's whatever was said.
I think you put that on.
Yeah, I did. I'm not blaming you.
I'm just saying we're a little fast in these...
The rules lean towards inclusion,
except when they lean towards exclusion.
The rules are whatever I say they are
in the moment, subject to change.
Next book, "Dopamine Nation" by Anna Lembke, great book.
"Regeneration" by Paul Hawkin.
Great one.
"Your Turn" by Julie Lythcott-Haims.
"The Awaken Brain" by Lisa Miller.
"Stolen Focus" by Johann Hari.
A nuevo classic.
Yes. And "Transcendence" by Scott Barry Kaufman.
That's book was written in 2021,
although he was a guest in 2022.
So again you do your interpretation.
I feel like "Bravey" is winning this.
What's that?
I think it's gonna be between "Bravey" or "Think Again,"
Adam Grant or Alexi.
Maybe, we'll see.
That's my feeling.
We'll see. What's next?
Best Rich Roll Nuevo obsession.
Sprouting, weight lifting, but heavy.
Yeah heavy weight.
So, all right.
The nominees are sprouting.
It's sprouting, sprouting.
And how's your sprouting going?
It's fallen off a little bit. I'll be honest.
I saw that coming.
Yeah.
(Adam laughing)
Keep going.
How about your weight lifting, your lifting heavy.
Well, once I started swimming a lot,
I had to back off the weights.
So now I spend the winter getting strong
and then now I'm in the pool.
So I'm not doing as much in the gym as I was.
But if that's your cup of tea, "Decoding the Gurus."
Take one.
We haven't talked about it yet.
I wanted to give you a little place to talk about it.
You love this podcast.
I love these guys.
Yeah.
Yeah. They're fantastic.
"Decoding the Gurus" podcast.
"Ice Baths."
You like "Ice Baths?"
I do like "Ice Baths."
"Adam's Swim Mask."
That is everybody's ultimate obsession, is it not?
(Adam laughing)
Should we just announce the winner
of this category right now?
There you go, folks.
All right. The next one.
This next category I don't know.
This was your idea.
I'm distancing myself
for any responsibility for this category.
Here it is, ready?
Luckiest Rocker of all time.
Ringo Star, George Harrison, or Ringo Star?
Jason's gonna have a beef with you I guess.
(Adam laughing)
Yeah, all right do what you will with that.
Personally, I'm voting for George.
The dystopia you would most want to live in.
I Like this category.
Yeah I like this one too.
The nominees are "Dune".
With the giant caterpillars.
You want to be mining spice?
Is that the dystopian future for yourself.
I'm just saying if you'd want to mine spice
while dodging giant caterpillars, "Dune" is your world.
Not caterpillars, worms.
Sorry.
"Station Eleven."
I mean, they seem to have fun in "Station Eleven."
They're putting on Shakespeare plays,
they're cruising around, there's some jeopardy.
Your kids might end up in a weird youth cult.
(Adam laughing)
That's the risk. Not a lot of creature comforts.
You might have seen your entire family die.
Next nominee "Don't Look Up."
"Don't Look Up."
I mean that's where we're all living right now.
So you wanna stay where we are
and just live in denial until
we're all just eradicated overnight?
I think so.
I think I would choose three out of this.
I think I would too.
Yeah. And the fourth.
The fourth is "Squid Game."
"Squid Game" was rough.
Lots of riches on the upside, if you win the squid game.
Tough to win that game.
You gotta suffer through some bullshit though.
(Adam laughing)
Did you watch it finally?
Of course.
That's so good. All right.
Best performance by a scooper in a leading role.
This is another skull neck classic.
The Coldstone guy.
What's that guy's name again?
He's friends with Joanne...
He is friends with Joanne.
Number one, number two, Adam at Ben and Jerry's.
Of course, it's Adam at Ben and Jerry's.
I could win three Rollies.
You've rigged it.
You created the categories
and then slipped yourself into them.
I won three of these things.
I'm disqualifying you.
You know what?
This is about.
This is the tension between inclusion and fair play, Adam.
If I win my Rollies, I'm gonna smelt them on the air.
There you go, all right, we'll live stream it on the RRP.
Best streaming series.
No surprise these nominees,
because we've talked about them before,
by the way, is anybody even listening
or watching to this anymore.
(both laughing)
Does anybody care?
I think we could have clipped it a little bit.
I know, it's kind of ridiculous. Right?
We're gonna get through this, I promise.
The nominees are "White Lotus."
We love it. We've talked about it a lot.
"Station Eleven." We love it. We've talked about it a lot.
"The North Water," which I think is
the Rafael Nadal of the category
because this is an incredible limited series
that went underappreciated.
I think Colin Farrell gives like,
I wouldn't say the performance of his lifetime,
but an extraordinary performance.
This is the show about the whaling ship in,
I forget early the turn of the century.
And it's really quite something.
He's like the bad Lieutenant on a whaling ship. Right?
Sort of.
Yeah.
With a heart of gold.
Oh really?
Kind of ruthless.
You know how much I love in Bruce?
Colin is a revelation in this show.
New edition, nominee "Severance."
Yeah. It's 2022 show but fuck it. I like it.
I think it's pretty good.
You're not crazy about "Severance," are you?
I did not fall under the spell.
The slow moving odd.
That's part of the gestalt.
You have to acclimate to this world.
That's what you guys
who like "Severance," you look down upon us.
It's just that he gets turned up ever so slightly.
And then you wake up and you're at full boil.
You know what I watch mostly?
"Peppa the Pig?"
An elephant documentary on Disney.
"The Bernstein Bears."
No, it's that elephant documentary
on Disney narrated by Meghan Markle.
We watch it constantly.
Have you seen "Succession"
because that's the other nominee here.
You know, I've gotten into "Succession" lately.
Like starting from the beginning.
Starting from the beginning.
It's fantastic.
Yes.
All right. We're we're getting close to the end here.
Next category, best filmed content period.
Series, film, whatever.
Yeah.
Who are the nominees here?
Bo Burnham inside.
Check.
Denis Villeneuve.
That's so poorly pronounced.
It's Denis Villeneuve
Villeneuve.
For "Dune."
"Dune" is my favorite movie of the year.
I love "Dune."
Really?
Yeah. "The North Water" back with "The North Water."
Then we have "Severance," "Station Eleven,"
And you slipped a rogue nominee in there.
Yeah Rich's stealth TikTok account.
You know Adam, I wish I had like some Finstas.
That what the kids call them right?
You have some dance moves.
Wait till you guys see Rich Roll tap dance.
That will never be filmed.
Okay. Check the show notes.
I think it's time now for the honor Rollie,
which is our, you guys know what this is, right?
The lifetime achievement award.
It is time for the honor Rollie.
For exceptionalism and yeah,
we're almost at two hours here.
The lifetime achievement award
for the hardest working film professional.
Who could this be Adam?
This is an effort-based award.
You know how much I like working hard to achieve your goal.
Overcoming the talent deficit gap.
This is the Rafael Nadal of Rollies.
Right, there is only one person
who could possibly earn this award.
I'm gonna let you say it because you know him personally.
The award goes to Mr. Frank Grillo.
(Adam clapping)
There you go Frank.
Come on, give it up for this guy.
He's been around for a long time, but in 2021,
he had eight films come out.
And he has currently 11 movies
that are filming or in post production.
11. Hardest working man in show business.
And he has literally...
Maybe Yurkarsh could get the honor Rollie next year.
We'll see.
Oh nice. Yurkash, hear that?
I think but this year,
we gotta give it up for Frank Grillo,
he's in Malta right now filming a movie.
Trying to get him on the podcast.
It's just a scheduling thing.
Hopefully when he comes back from Malta...
He's huge in Malta. He's enormous.
He's worldwide.
He's gone worldwide.
They call him worldwide Grillo.
This guy knows how to act in an action movie.
This guy knows his action.
All right, we've got one more category.
All right. This is yours.
All right. Most overrated over hyped film of 2021.
Let's be honest.
There's only one nomination for this,
only one movie deserving of this title.
And that is "The Matrix Resurrections"
because that movie was fucking terrible.
(Adam laughing)
I was 20 minutes deep into that
when I looked at April,
and April looked at me and we're like, "No."
It hurts because I love "The Matrix" so much.
And I wanted so much to be good.
And I know Lana Wachowski was trying
to sort of play with our expectations
and upend what we thought that movie should be.
So some of it's purposeful,
but it just didn't work for me at all
No, well even the original sequels didn't work.
So I'm not surprised this one didn't work.
That's true.
But there's a competition,
a late coming competition in this category.
Who's that?
Adam's TikTok account. Short lived as it was.
That's not such a good joke, but you know,
I'll let you have it.
All right, sorry, I don't have a TikTok.
Are you gonna end it?
Oh, you just took it off?
All right. It's gone.
"The Matrix Resurrections."
We just give them the Rollie right now for that one.
We have two winners.
(ceremonial upbeat music)
So how did this go?
Should we do this again next year? Or was this a bust?
I think we do it again. I think we do it bigger.
I think we start earlier.
We even do, I think we need to stage it.
I think we need some staging.
We need to invite the honor Rollie to come and speak.
Yeah, I think we go bigger.
I think we go deep.
The production values are starting to escalate here.
The costs?
Let's just see how it lands with the audience first.
And if we get a bunch of hate mail,
then we'll see.
I know a great production designer
that can help us with this.
Who's that?
Zuma.
Okay.
You should see how he rearranges furniture.
All right. Enough. We're done.
That was the Rollies.
I've been kicked out...
Kicked from it. What you will.
It seems like you hated the Rollies.
I just don't like,
is this what people are tuning into the podcast for?
I don't know.
I don't know, but they will tell us.
We are taste makers.
Are we?
I'm not sure.
Do you feel like you're actually
making people's tastes, Adam?
No. I feel like, you know what?
This is the best. This is what I am.
I am the kind of guy
that at an art museum makes jokes about the art.
I am an art heckler.
You're basically an old man gen X.
I'm the guy that goes to the art museums
and can't not crack jokes
about whatever I see in front of me.
That's what I am.
That's what I want you to know about me.
Yeah. So therein is why I am. So you know...
What?
I don't know, verbose.
Verbose?
Fill in the blank. Maybe like tweet at us
and let the audience fill in the blank there
what that adjective should be?
My friend Kelton Reed,
who is the writer files,
has the writer files podcast, great podcast.
Said this about Will Smith's slap.
He said he wished it had been the stiff glove,
like a gentleman.
What does that mean?
You know, I challenge you to a dual Christopher Rock.
I like that.
Yeah. Yes.
Yeah. I don't know.
I don't really think that's the way that went down.
No.
But we have breaking news that the academy
is launching an investigation.
We just found that out.
Yeah. That is breaking.
During the break.
How dare you disparage my contest?
What are they gonna uncover? That it happened?
The deeper motivation?
No, I don't know.
Anyway. All right.
Let's wrap this up.
We're gonna put a pin in everything for now,
and we're gonna turn our attention
to my conversation with my coach, Chris Howarth,
who is gonna chime in as part of
this accountability strategy.
This is self-serving Adam,
like, I figure if I have Chris come on every two weeks
and I do this zoom call with him on like my progress
that will hold me accountable
for actually showing up to train
and following through on this open water swim race
that I've got planned.
I love it.
The idea here is...
Are you gonna tell people about the race?
You haven't actually unveiled the course yet.
I'm doing an open water swim race this summer.
Let's just call it it that.
And so it's sort of one hand like holding me accountable,
but hopefully the second motivation here
is to sort of pop the hood and let the audience in on,
on how the kind of vegan sausage is made.
In other words, like how I work with
and communicate and collaborate with Chris.
Who's been my coach since 2007
to hopefully give people a sense of how that dynamic works,
how I think about and go about preparing
for an athletic adventure in the midst of a busy life,
but also hopefully provide a sense of how you guys,
the audience might think about
and go about preparing for your own.
So again, this is the first in
what will likely be a series of brief check-ins
with Chris in this lead up, and I hope you enjoy it.
So I guess I'm saying this is me
and Adam signing off until next time.
Thanks for joining us on today's absurdist jaunt.
We'll see you back here in a couple weeks.
Any parting words of wisdom, Adam?
Don't slap strangers or friends.
It's a wise advice.
Under any circumstances?
Yeah, I'd say under any circumstances,
a slap is a very middle of the road gesture.
You can do better.
Either like full blown punch in the face or no violence.
Or stand down.
I'm gonna think about that.
Never slap.
All right. In the meantime, let's go to me,
chopping it up with the great Chris Howarth.
Good to see you, Chris.
I'm excited to embark upon this new little experiment here.
Unfortunately, I can't get you down here every other week
to do a proper in-person coach's corner.
But what I can do is check in with you
and do this segment where we are intending
to kind of hold me accountable on this trajectory
that I'm on to hopefully not drowned
and complete this 12 and a half mile open water swim
that I'm gonna be doing in June.
So I look forward to all of your words of wisdom
to make sure that I'm gonna be okay.
Well, it's good to have you back on board
the training train it's been sort of since swim run, right.
That's true. It's true.
I mean, that's the last time that I trained for anything
with any level of intentionality.
So it definitely feels good to put something on the calendar
and have a sort of north star to guide
how I'm making decisions about my fitness
and the rest of my schedule every single day.
Although my life is infinitely more complicated
than it was even during Oltolow
and certainly a thousand fold more complicated
than it was, in a good way than it was
when I was training for Ultraman.
So for me the big challenge is being okay
with not having a perfect track record
in terms of being able to do every single workout
and trying to hold it a little bit loose
and be flexible and make sure that I'm having fun.
And it's nourishing my life as opposed
to feeling really onerous and burdensome and a drag.
Yeah, that's the big difference too, right?
That it doesn't drain you of energy,
the workouts and the training, and having a goal,
an event to prepare for.
That it's something that excites you,
invigorates you and you look forward to,
and you have it awakens that passion
and that curiosity again,
versus something that just drags energy out of us,
as well as, you know, doesn't keep that same excitement
and motivation going.
You know I'm not a big fan of motivation.
I'm a fan of drive and something deeper
to pull us through this training,
but this, something to return back to,
a deep part of you quite honestly,
and re-awakening that swimming version of you will be fun.
Yeah. And a little bit scary,
like just scary enough, right?
That I can't be too much of a slacker.
Exactly, and that's I think you touched on it.
That's one of the most important things of choosing a goal.
It's gotta be a little bit scary.
You have to have a little bit of fear in there,
or else you're not gonna take it yourself
and the training as seriously.
Right, but I am excited to just do a swim event.
You know we're both swimmers, that's our background.
And then we both had our respective experiences
in multi-sport, but I haven't done just a proper open water,
super long distance swim in and out of itself.
And that's my strength, right?
Like why haven't I done this?
So I am kind of excited to see what that's gonna be like.
I think you're gonna love it.
I think you're really gonna enjoy it.
Now you'll see in the process
to getting a out there and doing a few test swims,
you know my coaching strategies
are always around simulations
and I think you'll enjoy those alone in lakes and so forth.
And just getting comfortable with
that all day swimming pace again and zoning out into that.
Yeah. We're not quite there yet.
We're not quite there.
I had swam with any regularity in a very long time.
So my reintroduction to doing anything structured
in the pool has been humbling to say the least.
And before we even dive a little bit more into that,
I think it's worth talking a little bit about
on the subject of kind of humility, I suppose.
What just transpired with respect
to Jesse Itzler doing Ultraman Arizona
on ostensibly very little training
and the guidance that you gave him
and what transpired on Instagram
that we all watched with glee seeing him complete
that very difficult race.
And then we had talked earlier about your,
and he credited you and thanked you profusely
for the guidance that you gave him.
And now you're on the receiving end of
a lot of inbound emails and text messages.
Like, and I can just imagine, it's like,
"Oh, Jesse did Ultraman, Arizona, no training.
How can I do Ultraman and no training?"
Or any endeavor on no training?
Exactly. Which kind of misses the point. Right?
Yeah, it does.
And, but that's the thing about him.
And when we had that discussion in Minnesota,
two weeks prior to him doing Ultraman
is that I know him well enough
that he has a consistent training background.
I know that he's been cycling some
that he's always a consistent runner.
And so he has a platform to launch from,
this isn't literally at a zero.
And he has a history in to do hard things,
especially from a mental standpoint.
So you put all those ingredients together.
I felt pretty good about saying yes.
(both laughing)
Which yeah, I can't imagine you would be so quick
to say with other people,
like he does have that background and the mental game,
you know, the mental fortitude,
which is kind of what he leads with.
Yeah. And we discussed this sort of never defer approach.
And quite honestly, you know,
it brought up bigger emotions
and bigger thoughts as we were talking about it
even post the event.
He's had a lot go on in the last week in his life,
but he also had the opportunity.
He lost his father quite honestly.
And so he had the opportunity by not deferring,
doing this event with his father watching
and still taking part in this visual activity
and seeing him suffer and work through this.
And he was so proud and like had he not done this?
Like it just the universe how bizarrely it aligned
in this respect.
I mean, I haven't even talked to him about this aspect,
but never defer, at least go through the filter process,
talk to the people around you
and take chances because you never know
what the adventure and the experience will bring.
And so it was a special event with him
and yeah, you know what we spoke every evening,
I texted him during the event
so that the crew could read him things and so on.
But we knew that with fueling
and hydration and the proper mindset,
there is a way, a narrow way to navigate through this.
And he did it.
Right. He had to really thread the needle.
I know that the swim was the scariest part for him,
and he caught a bit of a break with that
because the chop and the wind was so crazy
that they called the swim off.
When I think he was about a kilometer
or a kilometer and a half into it.
And he got a bit of a breather before getting on the bike.
So I think that, you know,
basically put him in a good position
to be able to complete this thing.
And he can always say that he is an Ultraman.
And had he wavered, like you've said,
or deferred, perhaps it never would've come around again.
Or it would've come around again in a way
where he would've been less suited
or prepared to be able to complete it.
Well, you and I have talked about this before,
and this is ties us back to your event.
It's more a question of our lives are not going
to get emptier anytime soon.
That's what I told Jesse.
I keep diluting myself about that though.
I keep thinking like, it's gonna calm down,
like to my grave, right?
No. And that's what I said to Jesse.
I was like, "Do you think in a year from now,
if you defer all of a sudden your schedule
is gonna be emptier?"
Like his schedule is filling up left and right.
With all the projects.
Exactly. So I said, "Let's just take it now while you can.
And you're healthy. You're not injured.
It's a key ingredient for something like this
and we'll find out."
And he lived a true adventure.
And that is where you don't know if this is a reality
or if you can finish
and you really have to dig into a place,
he knows what an endurance adventure is like already
when you're trained for it, he's done enough of those.
Well, guess what?
He got to do something very few of us ever get to do.
Do one untrained,
like showing up at a hundred mile run with no training
or something like that, like just imagine that.
So that was something I was extremely proud of his grits
and resolved with that he did not let any voice get
in the way of his finish.
Yeah, well speaking of voices getting in the way,
I've got lots of voices in my head
that are angling to get in my way
and often succeed in that regard,
but I am really encouraged
and excited about this preparation phase
that I'm in right now.
So we've been working together
with some degree of intentionality for only like,
I don't know, four, six weeks at this point I think.
And taking it very gradually,
but just the consistency in the pool.
Like it's already kicking in.
I have so much muscle memory from swimming
that I trust and know that with regularity,
it will come back even though I'm getting up there in years
and it's been good to be able to
just get in the pool every day,
see just the tiniest bit of incremental improvement.
And I feel myself doing what I always do,
which is why is this workout only 3,500?
Like I can go 5,000.
I was gonna comment on that.
I have enough time to stack another 1500 on top of this.
And I have to remember,
I remember this in our Ultraman ramps up
where I would start feeling really fit
and get anxious about wanting to up the volume prematurely.
And always remembering
that slow build is part of building that strong foundation,
because it will get hard and it will get harder
than you think it's gonna get in time,
but at the right time.
At the right time.
And again it's keeping you healthy
and injury free and motivated throughout.
And so many people will enter into a great event
or an adventure or an experience.
And the first, you know, 10, 14 days,
they're all, gung ho on the training.
And next thing you know, it's like,
"This is a lot more than my body can handle
and that my life schedule can handle quite honestly.
I jumped in a little bit too aggressively."
And so I was also noticing
that with you sort of trying
to cheat in a few 5,000 yard swims.
So I want to keep in mind,
we wanted to be sure that you know what we're doing and why.
And so we're first building your endurance
and your endurance is gonna be about doing the distance.
And then it's gonna be about stamina,
which is about doing the distance faster, right?
That's the difference between the two,
one is how long can you go?
And what the other one is, how long can you go fast?
or fast relative to what we're looking to do,
for the event that we're getting ready for.
And so your confidence in being able
to swim around 30,000 yards is what you're sort of thinking
is going to revolve around us gently building our weeks,
so that then we can put the windows of training together,
where you have some extra time
that we can do some serious volume
and you build that confidence in a healthy
and enjoyable way,
because if your shoulders start hurting
or you're just depleted,
that's not gonna do us any good in May,
if your event is in June.
We wanna avoid that,
we wanna peak at the right time
and also build the confidence along with it
so that you hit the event, knowing, "I can do this."
I'm certainly not gonna head into this
with the kind of lack of preparation
that Jesse approached Ultraman,
but here we are at the beginning of May.
And this thing is in June.
Like that's not that much time.
It is a little bit scary.
And I think that motivates me like,
"Hey man we gotta make some hay here
or this is gonna be a disaster."
Well, and that's why we're sort
of gonna break it down into weeks where,
well, let's say 12 weeks to go.
12, 13 weeks, no pressure,
but that we have, you know, a long workout,
a long aerobic workout that you feel comfortable
and just not paying attention to pace,
but just swim your all day pace and do some long sets.
We'll do something where we're gonna do a lot of intervals
and steady state work where you feel
you look good about once again,
the stamina that you're building.
So how fast you're holding the steady states,
not best effort,
but just this is faster than I usually would swim.
But now I'm doing eight 200s or six 300s
instead of just shorter or less volume.
And then we'll do some workout
with some speed and drills in it,
so that you get your power back
and integrate all that into your swimming economy
so that you get back into the pool
and those thousands or eight hundreds
of going at all day pace feel really comfortable, steady,
and you have good traction on your pull through.
Quick footnote. I said, May I meant April?
We're at the beginning of April,
but either way, not that much time, it's been fun,
kind of on Instagram showing like the, you know,
I write out the workout in a Sharpie
and then I share it on Instagram stories
because I think people who aren't immersed
in the world of swimming,
think you just go to the pool
and you swim back and forth until your time is up.
And that's very far from the truth.
Everything is broken up into sets.
Every set has an intention.
And I'm always trying to read between the lines
when I look at the sets that you come up for me and think,
what is the purpose of this?
Like, why is this set coming after this one?
Oftentimes it's sort of like,
"Oh I see he wants me to ramp up to some tempo
or do a little bit of hypoxic breath work
and then go right into an aerobic set
to see how my body responds and how long
or quickly I can return to that baseline."
So it's all about like different modalities for acclimating
to an endurance race and then mixing it up with obviously
all the kind of technique based stuff drills, kick,
making sure all your body parts
are being trained properly as well.
Yeah. I mean you gotta figure,
we can't go out and swim 22,000 yards each workout, right?
You'll get really gassed up, therefore...
I can do that once.
I couldn't do that at all right now.
So therefore,
how do we make a 4,000-yard workout affect
when you're getting ready for 20,000 yards?
And so creating fatigue pockets, intensity breath work,
things like that,
and then returning to your go all day pace,
will highlight to you
how you're progressing in your fitness.
Creating insertion points that are supposed to fatigue you
and now how does that feel swimming a 400,
a 300 or a steady set from that?
And that's where we're at right now.
One of the other pieces to this
that I kind of presented you with is the idea
of building in some cycling into this
for the sole purpose of expanding my aerobic
like zone two base because I can ride my bike longer
than I can swim in the pool.
Right now I can go out for four hours, five hours,
maintain an elevated heart rate
for an extended period of time
without risk of injuring myself,
unless I get hit by a car or something like that.
Like I'm not gonna throw my shoulder out
or anything like that.
How do you think about that?
Like how beneficial is that going to be?
Should I just be in the pool
and maximizing that because we have so little time
or do you think that I'm getting a value add from that?
There is a value add, especially mentally
with regards to,
I know I can do a 2, 3, 4 hour activity right now,
where my heart rate is elevated.
And so that is definitely part of it.
I do that a lot with swimming and running as well.
I can go out, when I do a coast drive for example,
and I ride my bike six to eight hours a day.
Well that doesn't necessarily translate
into my running ability,
but it does translate to me
that I know I can do something continuously
for six to eight hours.
And so that helps build my confidence for running
and so forth.
And so that's how I would mainly approach it.
Yes, there is a fitness point in the beginning here
where your zone two and elevated heart rate,
just even in an aerobic space is going to be helpful,
delivering more oxygen into the working muscles
and so forth.
But eventually we're gonna hit a point where
that is truly active recovery
and mental space versus
the value of time in the pool, for sure,
but we're not there yet.
And I actually like that time out there
because you're using different muscles and the oxygen,
the stress is lower on the body.
So that then when you return to the pool,
there's a more intentional focus around it.
Right and it also gives my upper body muscles
a day to bounce back a little bit
so that when I am in the pool,
it's not just junk miles or what have you.
I can be a little bit more focused and fresh
and try to get the most out of it.
Yes. For sure.
One question about zone two.
So when I'm on the bike,
like I know what my zones are, heart rate wise,
assuming they haven't varied dramatically
from what they used to be, but when I'm in the pool,
I'm not wearing a heart rate monitor.
I'm not really paying attention to that.
I do have, I could be like a total tried dork
and wear that stuff in the pool.
Lots of people do that.
And stop your watch.
And you gotta stop your watch after every 150.
And click it when you do the drills
to make sure that it's logging your yardage accurately.
Yeah. For kicking.
Yeah, exactly.
Because I have such a, like yourself,
like such a robust background in swimming,
like I'm pretty connected.
I know what my kind of effort levels are to achieve that,
but if somebody's watching this or listening to it
and they're thinking about how
they're approaching their training in the pool,
how does the conversation around zones apply to that person?
That's where we often have an 800 or a 600
or a 500 at the end of a swim practice,
sort of where you jump into your all day pace.
We wouldn't do it as much by heart rate,
but we're not gonna be testing heart rate,
but at the end of a workout, let's say, you say, all right,
I'm just gonna no clock or get my time for 500,
but it's gotta feel like my go all day swim pace.
Like I'm gonna go swim the next two,
three hours at this pace,
I would usually suggest at least 500.
I personally do a thousand.
And then that pace gives me a good idea
of what my true aerobic zone 2 swimming pace would be.
So for us let's say,
just so that you get a number around it,
let's say it's 120 right now, 121.
Literally you just go all day pace.
If I had to swim 10,000 straight right now,
at what effort level would I start?
And that's what I wanna swim that thousand that,
well over time, we'll notice from that sensation.
What we usually know is heart rate
when we're outside biking and running,
that that time will come down.
Same effort level that it's going down to a 118
and then 117.
So we keep one sensation, the same output level,
feel RPE, and the time improves as we're getting fitter,
but we want that at the end of the workout.
Otherwise our RPE and our sensation
is gonna be a little bit off.
So that's why it's key to sort of burn off
the anaerobic juices and especially muscle glycogen 2.
And then with those tanks empty,
you get a better sense
and RPE of what you are truly going at aerobic pace at.
One of the techniques that you have deployed
with me over the years, that I think is really effective,
is making sure that your key discipline
is being trained under fatigue, right?
So in Ultraman, you never want to go out
and run on fresh legs
because that's not gonna be the experience at the race.
You always want your runs to be on the heels
of a very difficult cycling workout or swim workout.
So that every time you're running you're tired,
in this case because this,
it's just one discipline, but it is so long.
I suspect at some point during this training cycle,
you're gonna throw some stuff at me,
like maybe a difficult ride right before that swim.
So how do you think about,
or what do you have in store for me
in terms of stressing me in that way.
I love negative split swimming.
Where you have to start the first half of whatever it is
and make the second half faster.
So that you A, you learn your pacing,
but B, you really have to dig deep
in order to make that second half faster.
So you're coming into that second half
of those 800s of those 1000s of let's say, 4100s,
each 10, you're progressing the interval,
things like that where you were coming into the last 10
with a pretty good load on the arms
and the body and the whole system.
So similarly like that,
now of course we can do with cycling,
but it's a different type of fatigue.
It's actually in my opinion, a little bit better running,
but again we don't need that for what you're planning to do.
I think what you're gonna find is long swim workouts,
and then having a money set as I like to call it,
at the back end.
So let's say you just swam a 6,000 or 7,000 yard workout,
and then we do a money set and you're like,
"Oh really?"
Putting the main set at the very end of the workout.
Exactly, exactly.
And again that builds confidence
that knowing at two hours in,
I can still do X, Y, Z. That feels good.
One of the things that I always experience,
and I've shared this in the training logs with you,
when I start to get back in the water with some consistency,
is that I begin with one gear.
Like I have an aerobic base
so I can get in and swim back and forth fine,
but the minute I have to ramp it up
and do something hard,
My arms won't do what my brain is telling them to do
because I don't have the strength.
And to the extent that I can ramp it up a little bit,
I can't sustain it for any significant period of time.
Like I just completely fall apart.
So as we build that aerobic base
and start throwing down some tempo sets
and descending sets, etc.
That starts to slowly come together,
and then I start paying attention
to what we were talking about earlier.
Like how many gears do I have?
Can I go to two gears and then three gears
and four gears, and how much control do I have?
Like if I'm doing a set of descending 100s,
can I really lock in and make sure
that I'm inching down in time with each one
in a consistent way and the better adapted
I am to doing that, the more fit I am
and the more quickly my body will reset the baseline,
particularly on short rest,
that's a really good indicator
that the fitness is starting to come online.
As well as what you're also gonna notice
is you are your understanding, your feel of pace
is gonna be critical in open water.
So you don't start too hot or too slow on event day.
And you wanna be able to know
what that pace is no matter what,
even if you're hungry, even if you're fatigued,
even if you're whatever it is,
whatever the burden on you is
that you still can click into
whatever your open water swim pace is.
Or at least you can feel what 110 is like,
what 115 is like, and what 120 is like and so forth.
I was talking to somebody today,
he's doing a last man standing event.
It's gonna be critical that you know your pace
and the same thing for open water, there's no clock.
So you wanna be able to just know,
"Okay, I'm swimming pretty well.
I can feel my pace is going very well."
One of the things that I have to get comfortable with
is knowing that I'm gonna show up at this race,
not as fully prepared as I would like to.
And that kicks in a lot of ego stuff.
Like I don't want to tow the line,
unless I know that I've put in 110%
and earned the right to be there
and have taken it seriously, etc.
And that's just not the reality of my busy life.
So can I show up at 65% or 70%,
depending upon how busy I get?
You're just like every one of my other athletes.
I can't, and like still have fun
and let go of all of that other bullshit
because who the fuck cares?
Exactly. Well, your current 110%, that's the key.
That's key that unlocks this all.
You cannot compare yourself to 25-year-old Rich,
35-year-old Rich, 45-year-old Rich.
It's your current 110%.
If you feel you did what you could going into this event,
it takes so much of a burden off.
You can't be somebody different, you can only be you.
And your ability to do what you currently can,
that's going to be critical.
That's showing up with intention
because you know this is all I can do.
I'm not, futzing around watching Netflix all day.
I've got a busy life, but when I do show up,
I give it my best and come event day,
you will have that to fall back upon.
Is there always wishful thinking of,
"Well, back in the day, I could have done this?"
Of course there is.
But you can't be that person again, that's the past.
And you're gonna not enjoy your day
and this experience nearly as much,
if you're stuck in the past version of yourself.
I will say that it's a lot less time consuming
to just swim than to do all the other nonsense.
That takes up so much time, you know?
It's like, wow an hour and a half and I'm done for the day
and it's just, yeah, it's on the way to work or whatever.
It's like, that's not so bad.
Yeah, the main thing is for me over the next week or so,
or two weeks is that you really understand what we're doing,
why we're doing it
and get a good sense of where we're progressing to.
And like we talked about, we have some longer workouts,
we have some shorter stuff.
If you have extra time,
I'm gonna give you an extra workout or two
and put it into training peaks
so that you can choose from the library
and draw down from that.
And that we sort of navigate through these next two,
three weeks with some consistency
that you'll feel good like,
"I'm progressing, I'm not just treading water,
I'm progressing."
And you're gonna find that just being in the pool frequently
is gonna automatically do that for you.
Yeah, so much of it is the consistency.
But final thing I wanted to ask you is,
what are my blind spots right now?
When you're looking at my logs
or you're thinking about getting me ready
and you knowing me as well as you know me,
like when you have a shake your head moment,
what is it that you want to tell me?
(both laughing)
Well, one, it's training where you are
and not where you want be.
That's the key and that's when you jump ahead
and do the 5,000 yards because it feels good.
And of course in our mind,
we go, "Okay, that's a quarter of the race, that's great."
I can already in March do a quarter of my day,
but again we're building along a plan.
There's a path, there's a clarity to where we're heading.
And so we gotta trust the process, number one.
And then secondly,
you've brought both the things up already.
The other one is be good to yourself.
This is gonna be fun. This is where you exhale.
This is where we don't wanna judge ourselves
and compare ourselves to past versions,
but just really embrace.
Look at this, I get to swim outside in California
on my way to work, feel great, have a lot of energy,
fill my cup before I go to work
in just good physical activity.
It's something I love to do.
We always get outta the water feeling awesome
and like invigorated and that was pretty good.
Yeah, our arms might be a little tired,
but the whole cleansing aspect of swimming is so powerful.
And yeah, go with those two things,
it's gonna be fine.
You're gonna have a blast doing this event.
I think you're really gonna enjoy open water swimming.
I'm excited for you and you will be ready.
It's like what I told you
when you just did wildflower triathlon
way back many years ago.
And you're like,
"Dude, I'm thinking about Ultraman."
And I was like,
"I'll get you ready."
This isn't the question of if,
just a question of how.
Well, if nothing else just having this conversation
with you and sharing it publicly,
which makes me feel very vulnerable,
makes it so much less likely
that I'm gonna like cop out and then not show up.
So if it serves no other master,
other than to hold me accountable to show up,
then I know that's part of your dastardly plan,
but it's effective.
Yeah. It's training weeks, not workouts.
Keep that in mind, training weeks, not workouts.
So you just keep stacking the workouts.
You'll stack the training weeks and it'll all come together.
Excellent man. Well, I'll do my best.
And I'll check in with you in another two weeks publicly
And you can take my address
and tell me what I'm doing wrong
and tell me what I'm doing right.
And we'll just go from there.
Remember, be intentional with the whole thing.
And also as you're going through it,
something I always like to tell athletes is,
what does this look like when it's going well?
So as you look ahead of your week of training
and go what does this week look like
if it went really well?
On Friday, how will wear on Sunday,
how will I look back and go,
"You know what? That was a pretty good training week."
It takes us out of the intervals
and the pace and more bigger picture.
I had a good week.
Yeah, one of the things that you've done
is kind of create a bunch of workouts.
And then I say to you what,
I'm not sure which days these are gonna work,
because my schedule is very fluid
and being a little bit loose with that.
Like just if you get these three things in
on whatever days and then if you have extra time,
you can work this in, but if you can't,
don't worry about it because the core is taken care of.
Exactly.
All right my friend.
Well, I appreciate the guidance as always.
It's been, how many years has it been?
We started 2007, late 2006.
Yeah.
It's when this conversation began.
I still have that first email.
Oh you do?
That introductory email from Gavin.
Oh, I'd like to resurface that.
I'm sure I have it too, but forward it to me.
That's that would be fun to see.
Well thank you
for all the sound advice and guidance.
Absolutely. And our circle closed again.
Gavin swam with me this morning.
Oh he did. Wow.
For those that don't know my roommate,
when I lived in San Francisco
and the initial point of contact between the two of us.
He is steady as they go,
the most consistent human being I've ever met.
(both laughing)
We love you Gavin.
Well, I'll talk to you soon. Thanks Chris.
All right. Thanks Rich.
(slow-paced brisk music)